Sanktuarium ist das griechische Schlüsselwort für einen Ort, der einen Zuflucht bietet.
Hallo, hier ist Chaos Radio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 113. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle Hörer da draußen unter ihren Kopfhörern, wie auch immer sie herein oder herübergestülpt sind. Heute geht es um Karten oder genauer, heute geht es um Geografie, man könnte vielleicht auch sagen Neogeografie. Das alles gilt es zu ergründen. Im Mittelpunkt steht allerdings ein Projekt, was vielleicht manchen von euch auch schon bekannt ist oder zumindest werdet ihr immer was davon gehört haben, von OpenStreetMap, ein neuer Ansatz im Bereich Geodaten und um darüber kompetent zu diskutieren, habe ich mich nach Karlsruhe begeben und begrüße für die heutige Sendung zwei Gäste, nämlich den Frederik, Frederik Ramm. Hallo. Und Jochen Topf, hallo. Ja, ihr beide seid ja sehr umtriebig im Bereich der Geodaten. Ich bin auf euch gestoßen, weil ihr ja auch, ja, euch nicht nur so ein bisschen hobbymäßig damit beschäftigt, sondern auch schon da versucht, ein kleines Business draus zu machen. Da können wir später auch vielleicht noch mal darauf eingehen. Aber im Mittelpunkt steht natürlich jetzt vor allem erstmal die Frage, was eigentlich diese Bewegung, die sich ja, wie zumindest mal eine distante Wahrnehmung ist, ganz gut entwickelt hat und eine Dynamik an den Tag gelegt hat, die schon so ein bisschen an die Dynamik der Wikipedia erinnert. Vielleicht nicht unbedingt in absoluten Zahlen, aber nur noch zumindest, was die Mobilmachung einer neuen Community betrifft bei OpenStreetMap. Was ist denn eigentlich das Problem gewesen, dass sich ein solches Projekt wie OpenStreetMap hat entwickeln müssen?
Im Prinzip ganz einfach. Jeder will Karten haben, jeder hat heutzutage in seinem Auto und Navigationsgerät. Jeder braucht Geodaten in irgendeiner Form für seine Projekte, aber diese Geodaten sind erstens meistens teuer und zweitens mal nicht frei. Man kann nicht alles damit machen. Man kann zu einer Firma hingehen und kann sagen, hier ich brauche jetzt mal eine Landkarte von einem bestimmten Bereich, eine Straßenkarte, was auch immer es ist und kann diese Daten kaufen. Die sind dann aber nicht frei im Sinne von Open Source oder Free Software, sondern sie unterliegen irgendwelchen Lizenzen, die einem zum Beispiel verbieten, sie im Internet darzustellen. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es natürlich viele kostenlose Karten inzwischen von Google Maps, von Microsoft, von vielen anderen Firmen, die man nutzen kann, solange man sich an die Nutzungsbedingungen hält, die aber zum Beispiel in der Regel erfordern, dass man sich so einen Lizenzkey holt und dann kann man auf seiner Website was einbinden, kriegt die Karten dann vielleicht auch sogar auf seiner eigenen Webseite, aber schon wenn man sie ausdrucken möchte und vielleicht mal ein paar Kopien verteilen, ein Anfahrtsplan zu seiner Party oder sowas, schon bei solchen einfachen Anwendungen stößt man häufig an die Grenzen, was der Lizenstechnisch möglich ist.
Da gab es ja in den späten 90ern, glaube ich, hier gerade in Deutschland diese Stadtplandienst-Net-Affäre, wo das war noch prä-Google Maps, da hatten aber relativ viele Städte oder einzelne Kartenanbieter hatten schon so kleinere Stadtplanportale oder sowas. Das war noch so eine Zeit, wo es halt, wo eben nicht jede Stadt einen gescheiten Stadtplan online hatte, aber manchmal gab es was. Und da gab es dieses stadtplandienst.net und die hatten das irgendwie so irgendwie gesammelt. Ich weiß auch nicht mehr genau, wie das lief. Und man konnte dann da Links setzen, praktisch so, da wohne ich, so ein Link auf so ein Bild, wo dann eben die Location schon rein codiert war. Dann kam das Bild mit so einem kleinen roten Kringel. Die hatten da auch so eine Nutzungsbedingung und stand drauf, für privaten Zweck kein Problem, Einsatz kostenlos. Und dann haben die irgendwann ihre Nutzungsbedingungen geändert und haben da hingeschrieben, ja, das ist ab jetzt, darf man das nur noch machen, wenn man irgendwie bei uns dann eine Lizenz kauft. Und haben dann angefangen, nach einiger, nach einer gewissen Kulanzfrist, einfach alle Leute abzumahnen, die da so einen Link auf der Seite hatten. Das war natürlich rechtlich, also das hat für einigen auch vorgesorgt. Also das ist so ein typisches Beispiel, wie die Nutzer halt denken, naja, da ist so ein kostenloses Angebot, das nutze ich mal. Und man nimmt gar nicht so wahr, dass das, obwohl das vielleicht kostenlos ist, eben trotzdem, dass man da an so einem Tropf hängt, der einem jederzeit auch abgedreht werden kann. Google heute hat kostenlose Karten, Jochen sagte ja schon, Nutzung ist eingeschränkt und Google sagt zum Beispiel auch, wir behalten uns das Recht vor, jederzeit da Werbung zu schalten auf diesen Karten. Das heißt, wenn du heute irgendwie für deinen Karnickel-Züchter-Verein da so eine schöne Google Maps auf der Karte hast, um zu zeigen, wo du bist, dann kann da halt übermorgen schon Google-Werbe-Pop-ups auf deiner Webseite erscheinen.
Tun sie aber noch nicht?
Tun sie noch nicht. Google hat in den Nutzungsbedingungen stehen, dass sie sich das vorbehalten und dass sie es aber, ich glaube, drei oder sechs Monate vorher ankündigen werden. Das heißt, immerhin werden sie die Nutzer nicht einfach so überraschen, aber das kann durchaus irgendwann kommen.
Ja, Google Maps hat ja auch so das Internet im Strom mal wieder übernommen, habe ich so den Eindruck, also so diesen Kartenbereich, weil sie einfach auch ein paar Dinge ganz klug gemacht haben, muss man auch dazu sagen. So gerade Stadtplandienst, man hat ja auf so eine Sache wie Embedding oder so sind sie irgendwie gar nicht gekommen und da hätten sie sich eine Menge Ärger sparen können. Interessant ist ja, dass sie sich durch diese Methoden letzten Endes alle selber out of business bringen. Also dass sie eigentlich so dieses Ganze rumgezicke, also sie es einfach auch nicht verstanden haben, da freundlich genug zu sein oder auch im Sinne eines Kundenverhältnisses zu denken. Wobei das sind ja nur reine Business-Entscheidungen, das soll ja auch letztlich nix zur Sache tun. Trotzdem, was man glaube ich feststellen kann, ist so kostenlos ist nicht frei. Man bekommt ja gar nicht die Daten bei Google Maps, sondern man bekommt ja eine Karte.
Man bekommt eine fertige Karte, die Google entscheidet, was auf der Karte erscheint. Google entscheidet, auf welche Weise das erscheint, dass Straßen bestimmte Dicke und bestimmte Einfärbung haben und all diese Dinge und man bekommt nur genau das, was Google einem da vorsetzt und genauso ist es bei quasi allen anderen großen Betreibern auch. Man kann dann obendrauf irgendwie kleine Punkte setzen und kann sagen, hier habe ich jetzt mein Fähnchen, wo irgendwas ist und kann dadurch in begrenzter Weise Einfluss nehmen. Inzwischen ist es, muss man sagen, technisch gar nicht schlecht, was da alles möglich ist. Man kann heutzutage auch mehr als nur Fähnchen draufsetzen und kann Linien und Flächen drüber einzeichnen und so weiter, aber es ist immer nur was, was oben drüber ist. An die Grunddaten kommt man nicht ran. Das ist das, was ist einfach fest vorgegeben. Und wenn man, ich sag mal, die Karte nur in einer anderen Sprache vielleicht haben möchte, dann ist das schon nicht möglich.
Aber diese Daten gehören ja auch nicht Google im eigentlichen Sinne, oder?
Nee, Google kauft die einen, lizenziert die. Das steht ja immer, wenn man auf so einer Google-Map rum-surf, dann steht ja immer unten rechts in der Ecke, Data Copyright, Buy. Da sieht man, das ändert sich dann auch, je nachdem, welchen Ausschnitt man gerade anguckt. Sehr viel Tele-Atlas-Daten sind da, glaube ich, dabei bei Google, aber nicht ausschließlich, also durchaus auch zugekauft von anderen Anbietern in anderen Ländern. Das kaufen die aus ganz verschiedenen Quellen und mischen das zusammen. Die machen ihre Arbeit schon gut, Google, muss man sagen. Vorher war das so eine komische, zerklüftete Landschaft. Es gab dann irgendwelche Portale, die nur Tele-Atlas-Daten drauf hatten und dann ein bisschen mal irgendwo hin gesurft, wo Tele-Atlas nicht so gut war. Und dann fehlte das da. Google macht das schon gut. Aber letzten Endes sind die auch nur so ein Datendurchlauferhitzer. Wobei man sagen muss, die haben ja jetzt, sag ich mal, den Erfolg von OpenStreetMap zu kopieren versucht oder haben ihr Produkt Google Map Maker aufgelegt. Das ist auch so ein Community-basiertes Ding, wo Google sagt, es gibt bestimmte Gebiete. Ein Beispiel dafür ist zum Beispiel Island, wo wir gar keine Daten einkaufen können. Wir hier googeln mit unseren Taschen voller Geld. Wir sagen, verkauft uns bitte mal jemand eine gescheite Straßenkarte von Island. Und es gibt keine, zumindest keine in digitaler Form, die sie halt da in ihr System reinbringen können. Also haben sie sich da hochauflösende Luftbilder gekauft und haben das in so eine Elitierplattform reingeworfen. Die heißt Google Map Maker, wo dann praktisch jeder sich anmelden kann und sagen kann hier, ich trace da was ab vom Satellitenbild, ich schreibe da was rein. So ganz ähnlich wie bei OpenStreetMap, nur halt eben mit dem Unterschied, dass es proprietär ist. Das heißt, wenn man da irgendwas eingibt, dann gehört das alles nachher Google. Hälft Google. Genau, Hälft Google.
Weil diese Firma so bedürftig ist.
Und die sind jetzt gerade dabei, haben sie gerade im Beta aufgelegt, dass sie diese Map Maker Sachen, auch dass man die tatsächlich auch in der Form einer normalen Google-Karte anschauen kann. Also da arbeiten die jetzt auch, versuchen die auch Daten selber mit zu erheben.
Doof sind sie ja nicht.
Ne, das, also ich muss auch sagen, wir profitieren natürlich auch in vielen Punkten davon, dass Google da so den Markt geebnet hat. Google hat das ja praktisch, dass die Leute jetzt sagen, ja klar, mache ich auf meine Webseite so eine kleine Karte, so eine Slippi-Map nennt sich das, wenn du diese Karte so verschieben kannst mit der Maus, mit der Mausrad rein und rauszoomen. Das ist ja auch diese ganze Art des User-Interfaces. Das hat Google sich ja etabliert. Heute brauchst du nur noch das nachzubauen und dann kann jeder sofort eine Karte bedienen. Das ist was, wo man ganz klar sagen muss, danke Google, dass ihr das zu einem ganz normalen Produkt gemacht habt und in dessen Windschatten wir jetzt da auch so ein bisschen segeln können. Wir können sagen, wir bieten euch praktisch ungefähr das Gleiche wie Google, aber noch die folgenden zehn zusatzcoolen Sachen, die Google eben euch nicht bieten kann.
Du hast jetzt gerade das Beispiel Island gesagt. Es gibt ja auch Länder, wo es auch so rein rechtliche Probleme gibt. Wenn ich richtig informiert bin, ist es zum Beispiel auch in Indien, zumindest bis vor Kurzem, noch überhaupt nicht erlaubt gewesen, Karten zu publizieren, die jetzt sozusagen nicht unter der Ägide des Staates stehen.
Man brauchte wohl eine Lizenz in irgendeiner Form oder irgendeine Genehmigung vom Staat. Und die haben sich dann die Karte angeguckt, bevor sie gesagt haben, es ist in Ordnung. Die haben wohl auch immer noch, es ist unklar, wie die Situation jetzt im Detail wirklich ist. Aber die haben halt Bedenken, dass da jemand zum Beispiel die Grenze zu Pakistan, die halt umstritten ist, falsch einzeichnet. Und solche Sachen sind denen wichtig. Und deswegen hat sich da nie so eine richtige Kartenindustrie und Geodatenindustrie bilden können wohl in Indien. Indien ist einer von den Ländern, wo Google mit Mapmaker jetzt sehr, sehr aktiv ist.
OpenStreetMap auch?
OpenStreetMap weniger. Also ich hab da noch nicht so wahnsinnig viel gesehen. Es gibt vor, wann war das, vor einem Jahr etwa, glaube ich, war ein OpenStreetMapper, ist da nach Indien gefahren und hat da so eine Aktion gemacht, dass er hat sich von einigen Universitäten quasi einladen lassen und hat ihnen mal gezeigt, wie das mit dem OpenStreetMap funktioniert, um da so die Community ans Laufen zu bringen. Und das hat wohl ganz gut funktioniert, aber es ist halt einfach ein verdammt großes Land. Und auch ein, ich sag mal, untertechnisiertes Land im Vergleich jetzt zu uns. Und es fällt ihnen natürlich schwieriger, da was zu machen. Grundsätzlich ist es aber so, dass OpenStreetMap doch auch in Schwellenländern, in Entwicklungsländern am Aufholen ist und dass da eine ganze Menge passiert jetzt in letzter Zeit.
Ist ja auch ein richtiges Asset für so einen Staat, gute Karten zu haben. Also du magst ja eine Stadt so oder so sehen, aber wenn man die nicht hat, dann hat man auf jeden Fall erstmal ein Problem.
Ja, allerdings, diese Erkenntnis ist eine Erkenntnis, die sich sehr langsam verbreitet. Also es gibt ja heute noch viele Staaten, die das als große Gefahr für die nationale Sicherheit ansehen, wenn jeder einfach so Karten, insbesondere eben Karten, die nicht von der zentralen Behörde abgesegnet sind, bekommen kann.
Wo kommen wir denn dahin?
Genau, also es gibt durchaus Länder, also dazu zählen Ägypten, Saudi-Arabien und China, wo man als Ausländer verhaftet wird, wenn man mit einem GPS-Gerät rumläuft. Also da muss man aufpassen. Wir haben natürlich trotzdem Undercover-OpenStreetMapper in diesen Ländern, die da eifrig arbeiten. Aber das ist dann schon ein bisschen ein anderes Kaliber. Ich meine, das passierte hier auch. Karlsruhe ist ja nun schon relativ gut erfasst. Und die Leute überlegen sich ja, was kann man noch für Details. Jetzt haben wir mal neulich angefangen, Überwachungskameras alle zu mappen hier in Karlsruhe. Da hat einer da neulich bei der Bundesanwaltschaft, der hat mit seinem Fahrrad so dreimal drum herum gefahren und hat die ganzen Überwachungskameras da aufgenommen. Da ist aber auch dann hinter dem plötzlich ein Auto hergefahren mit Leuten, die ein bisschen genauer beobachtet haben, was er da macht. Also ich meine, ist in Deutschland noch nicht so, dass du dann da einfach plötzlich im Knast verschwindest. Also sind diese Fälle nicht bekannt.
Aber ja. Das sind ja auch Zustände, wenn die Leute jetzt auch noch ihre Überwacher überwachen.
OpenStreetMap ist grundsätzlich kein Projekt, das um Erlaubnis fragt. Dadurch, dass wir halt so verteilt sind und jeder lädt irgendwas hoch. Die Datenbank steht irgendwo in London, was noch halbwegs rechtssicherer Raum ist. Das heißt, wir hatten bislang auch nicht irgendwelche Request. Zum Beispiel in Deutschland, wenn da irgendwo eine Kaserne ist, da ist natürlich auch eine Kaserne eingezeichnet. Wenn einer mal am offenen Tag der offenen Tür da reinkommt und die Wege innerhalb der Kaserne kartiert kriegt, dann werden die auch eingezeichnet. Da denkt keiner lange drüber nach. Aber es gibt durchaus Kartenmaterial, in dem auch in Deutschland Kaserne ausgespart sind und so erscheinen, als ob da einfach nur ein Acker wäre oder so was.
Also, ja.
Ja, das scheint wirklich ein beliebtes Element zu sein. Ich erinnere mich auch noch so, als es mit der DDR zu Ende ging und dann wurden dann auch mal so ein bisschen die Karten überprüft. Da waren dann auch so Wandlitz, ja, also das Refugium der Staatsführung. Das war zwar jetzt als solches schon auf Straßenkarten erhalten, aber es waren nicht alle Straßen, die dorthin führen, eingezeichnet. Also vor allem nicht die dicke breite Straße, die dann so von der Autobahn da extra hingebaut wurde, damit die Herren auch schnell an ihr Seeschlösschen fahren können. Und Dinge sind dann auch manchmal woanders gewesen. Also hat es dann halt einfach mal ein bisschen verschoben. Es ist natürlich jetzt ein sehr interessanter Bereich mit dieses, welche Daten werden denn überhaupt erfasst. Bevor wir da vielleicht jetzt mal auf den Blickwinkel von OSM kommen, fände ich es nochmal ganz interessant, einfach mal zu schauen, jetzt im kommerziellen Bereich. Wenn ich also jetzt losgehe und ich habe einfach eine Menge Kohle in der Hand und kann mir das jetzt mal leisten, so wie Google das eben offensichtlich macht. Zu wem kann man denn überhaupt hingehen? Also der Name Teleatlas ist schon gefallen. Wen gibt es noch? Und welche Daten kann man denn überhaupt bekommen?
Also es gibt zwei große Player in dem Business. Das ist Teleatlas und das ist Navdeck. Navdeck, eine amerikanische Firma, und Teleatlas, eine europäische Firma. Die sind beide letztes Jahr gekauft worden. Teleatlas, hilf mir mal weiter, ich kann es mir nie merken.
Teleatlas von TomTom, Navdeck von Nokia, das sind die Anfangsbuchstaben passen.
Ah ja, genau, ok. Gut, daran muss man sich es merken. Und die haben, ich sage mal, mehr oder weniger die Welt unter sich aufgeteilt. Also man kriegt von sehr, sehr vielen Ländern von dem einen, mindestens dem einen oder dem anderen, kriegt man Straßendaten. Die haben vor allen Dingen, also denen ihr Ziel ist, vor allen Dingen Daten zu erfassen für die Straßenavigation. Das heißt, die haben die Straßen, die haben aber auch Informationen, eben wie viele Spuren hat die Straße. Und wenn man da links abbiegen will, dann geht man muss mal auf die linke Spur vor und so weiter, damit all diese Informationen, die im Navigationsgerät dann nachher rüberkommen sollen, dass sie die haben, die haben auch Informationen darüber, wie vielleicht Höhenbeschränkung ist oder dafür darf kein Schwerlasttransport hier fahren oder solche Dinge.
Also alles, was für den Verkehr wichtig ist, diese Sachen erfassen die alle.
Die haben auch, sag ich mal, so Points of Interest, Tankstellen, Restaurants, Hotels, diese typischen touristischen Sachen haben sie schon auch. Und außerdem, ich meine, neben Tele, Atlas und NAV, da gibt es dann halt noch so regionale, also es gibt dann, man findet dann so für jedes Land, das man betrachtet, wahrscheinlich noch ein, zwei Firmen, die irgendeinen originären Datensatz für dieses Land haben, aber die praktisch dann nur regional aktiv sind oder so.
Und was natürlich auch gibt, sind die Gemeinden- und Landesvermessungsämter und so weiter, also diese ganze öffentliche Schiene. Da gibt es in jedem Land irgendwelche Behörden oder quasi Behörden, die die Daten erfassen. In Deutschland sind das Landesvermessungsämter oder auch die Gemeinden, die halt für lokale Sachen zuständig sind, aber auch Straßenverkehrsbehörden und das Umweltschutzamt, für denen ihre Sachen zuständig sind. Weil es gibt eine unglaubliche Zahl von Behörden, die Daten erfassen und die die auch verkaufen. Die Daten sind nicht unter offenen Litenzen zu bekommen oder irgend sowas, sondern die verkaufen die auch, versuchen darüber ein bisschen Geld wieder reinzubekommen. Und es ist häufig sehr, sehr schwierig, da irgendwo herauszufinden, wer ist denn eigentlich derjenige, der mir die Daten da überhaupt geben kann. Nicht nur, dass man sie bezahlen muss, man muss erst mal herausfinden, wer ist denn jetzt der, der diese Daten hat, weil es in dieser föderalen Struktur usw. sehr schwierig ist. In England zum Beispiel ist es etwas einfacher. Da gibt es diese Ordnance Survey, die da eine sehr starke Position hat, die quasi so eine Mischorganisation ist, aus einer Behörde hervorgegangen, aber jetzt so halber privatwirtschaftlich eben und so was. Und viel Geld damit auch einnimmt, dass sie ihr Kartenmaterial, was zugänglichermaßen sehr, sehr gut ist, verkauft.
Diese vor allem auch wirklich wie Produkte verkaufen. Ich meine, unsere Vermessungsämter in Deutschland machen das ja nicht. Also wenn wir zumindest neu oder gibt es tatsächlich so etwas?
Die Vermessungsämter haben zum Teil schon richtig gedruckte Karten. Also diese normalen Toppokarten, die du kriegst, da steckt immer Vermessungsmaterial dahinter. Die werden natürlich von Verlagen vermarktet und so. Die Vermessungsämter haben allerdings oft zumindest Webseiten, wo dann genau steht, hier von uns kriegt sie das folgende Material. Und können sie hier auf CD ordern und kostet dann 10 Euro dafür, dass wir die CD brennen plus 5 Euro Porto plus noch für jeden Quadratkilometer so und so viel 1000 Euro und irgendwie so eine Fantasieaufstellung, was das denn kosten könnte. Unser Verdacht ist, dass die meisten, dass man irgendwie diesen Leuten so ein bisschen eingeimpft hat. Geodaten, das ist ein großer Markt, das ist viel Geld, was ihr da habt. Ihr sitzt da auf großen Werten. Und dass die irgendwie denken, sie müssten da jetzt irgendwie viel Geld verdienen und dass sie dann damit sich irgendwelche Preise ausdenken und Preislisten aufstellen und mal so einen kleinen Vertriebsapparat da. Dass sie letzten Endes dann aber wahrscheinlich mehr Geld damit verschleudern, da irgendwie die drei Bestellungen, die sie im Jahr haben, zu bedienen, als da jemals rauskommt. Man weiß es nicht genau.
Also den Eindruck hatte ich auch. Ich kann mich noch erinnern, ich habe vor 2009, ziemlich genau vor zehn Jahren, ich glaube sogar exakt vor zehn Jahren, brauchte ich mal ein Luftbild. Da haben wir nämlich unser erstes Camp organisiert. Das ist eine typische Anwendung für einen Privatnutzer. Man will halt eine Open Air-Veranstaltung machen. Bei einer Open Air-Veranstaltung ist es immer echt praktisch, wenn man alles von oben sieht. Dass man einfach selber sich eine Karte machen kann. Es gibt ja sowas nicht mit Luftbildern. Gab es nicht. Und dann weiß ich auch noch, da bin ich irgendeinem Brandenburger Landesvermessungsamt gelatscht. Und dann war das so ein elend bürokratischer Prozess mit bestellen und Formular ausfüllen und Pipapo. Und dann kriegt man irgendwie Wochen später dann halt so einen Fotoabzug irgendwie zugeschickt. Und muss natürlich noch irgendeine Gebühr, die ich mich jetzt nicht erinnern kann, da entrichten. Und ich fragte mich halt schon damals irgendwie, warum geben die, wieso stellen die das nicht einfach der Gemeinschaft zur Verfügung? Weil dann würde sich das erstmal automatisieren. Mit so einem bürokratischen Verkauf, das ist ja alles nur Verschleiß. Und das führt ja nur dazu, dass diese Daten eigentlich nie wirklich genutzt werden. Gibt es da einen Sinneswandel in irgendeiner Form? Ich meine, es gibt ja gerade, gut bei uns jetzt im Berliner Raum, so Potsdam ist so eine Hochburg von so dieser, ich weiß nicht, wie man das nennen soll, GISS-Industrie. Also GISS, den Begriff werdet ihr kennen, also Geoinformationssysteme. Da gibt es so allerlei, naja, obskur, wenn ich das nicht sagen, aber so Unternehmungen und vor allem universitäre Projekte, die sich irgendwie in irgendwelchen Projekten da verdingen und auch mit Geodaten hantieren, wo aber nie so ganz klar ist, was da jetzt eigentlich wirklich gemacht wird und was dabei rauskommt.
Kennt ihr das? Ja, also ein bisschen sehen wir das natürlich auch, diese GISS-Industrie. Es gibt da durchaus eine ganze Menge und es gibt einfach wahnsinnig viele Leute, die heutzutage Geodaten brauchen. Es ist ja auch nicht nur Straßenkarten, es ist Satellitenbilder braucht man dazu, um zu sehen, zum Beispiel wie seine eigenen Kornfelder, wie das Korn wächst und wann wahrscheinlich der Tag sein wird, dass man da ernten kann, weil bevor man dahin fährt, wenn man ein großes Feld hat, kann man vom Satellitenbild diese Sachen sehen. Und was natürlich auch dazu kommt, man kann es auch beim Nachbarn sehen und weiß, wann der fertig sein wird. Und man weiß, wie die Ernte in einem anderen Land vielleicht sein kann, was auch für die nationale Sicherheit wieder wichtig sein kann, solche Dinge. Da wird wahnsinnig viel gemacht. Viele von diesen Sachen sind halt, wie du schon sagst, universitär oder hängen auch dann mit den Behörden wieder zusammen, mit den Staaten, die leben also von Staatsaufträgen häufig oder europäische Gemeinschaftsprojekte. Solche Geschichten gibt es da sehr viel. Es gibt aber durchaus auch Privatunternehmen und Entrepreneure, die so ein bisschen offener und moderner da vielleicht sind. Also es gibt durchaus Firmen, wo man hingehen kann und heutzutage Satellitenbilder oder Luftaufnahmen bekommen kann. Da muss man jetzt nicht mehr zum Start gehen. Inzwischen gibt es da genug Firmen, die sowas auch anbieten und bei denen es auch sicher einfacher sein wird als bei der Behörde.
Man kann ja mittlerweile sogar extra anfordern, dass der Satellit mal über das eigene Haus fliegen möge und da ein Bild machen. Also über das eigene Haus fliegen tut er sowieso, aber...
Bei wem kann man das anfordern?
Da gibt es ja eine Anzahl Firmen, die ausreichend Satelliten haben.
Also private Unternehmen jetzt?
Private Unternehmen, die das dann anbieten wollen. Du kannst dann jetzt bei der Behörde anrufen. Oder anfordern, ich brauche mal dieses Bild, aber möglichst aktuell. Und dann sagen die dir, wann das nächste Mal das Satellit drüber fliegt. Und dann schießen sie für dich da ein Bild. Also da schon einiges. OpenStreetMap hat gerade auch erstmalig selber Geld ausgegeben für Luftbilder. Und zwar für eine Aktion im Gazastreifen. Und jetzt, nach diesem Krieg, kann man irgendwie sagen, nach diesen Kampfhandlungen, die da stattgefunden haben, haben sie gesagt, also jetzt wäre mal wichtig, auch so für Hilfseinsätze und so weiter. Wir brauchen jetzt mal aktuelle Karte vom Gazastreifen und so. Wo alles in der Form auch festgehalten ist, wie es eben jetzt ist. Und nicht wie es vielleicht vor fünf Jahren mal gewesen ist. Und haben da dann sich halt umgeschaut und haben einen Anbieter ausgewählt, der ihnen aktuelle Luftbilder machen kann. Und haben da irgendwie, ich glaube, etwa 5000 Dollar investieren müssen für aktuelle Luftbilder vom ganzen Gazastreifen. Spenden gesammelt und dann diese Luftbilder beauftragt. Und da wird jetzt dann OpenStreetMap gemapped.
Und die Daten, die sie dann, also diese Bilder, die sie dann bekommen, die sind dann auch im einigen Sinne frei. Also können sie dann mitmachen, was sie wollen oder?
In diesem speziellen Fall war das, glaube ich, so, dass die die Bilder etwas günstiger bekommen haben und sich dafür auf die Bedingungen eingelassen haben, dass sie nur für eine geschlossene Benutzergruppe, also für eine bestimmte Anzahl von OpenStreetMap-Aktiven verwendet werden zum Abzeichnen, dass aber dann die daraus gewonnenen abgezeichneten Karten komplett frei sind unter OpenStreetMap-Lizenz.
Ja, verstehe. Es ist einfach nur so eine Zeichenvorlage.
Genau, so eine Art Leihgabe. Ihr mietet diese Bilder jetzt mal von uns für eine Zeit lang. Ihr dürft da alles abmalen. Und ihr dürft aber die Bilder an sich jetzt nicht frei weiter verteilen. Was ein Kompromiss ist, aber für den Anwendungszweck war das halt in Ordnung.
Ja, ich wollte nochmal, also bevor wir wirklich jetzt voll auf OSM einsteigen, ich finde das einfach mal auch sehr interessant, so den Ist-Zustand erstmal ein bisschen zu beleuchten. Wir haben ja gesagt, okay, Teleatlas, Navtech, die teilen sich sozusagen derzeit die Beute. Und dahinter stehen jetzt interessanterweise halt TomTom und Nokia. TomTom ist ganz klar sehr bekannt mit ihren Autos, mittlerweile auch so Motorrad-Navigationssystemen, was sogar, was sie noch alles so rausbringen, die auch ganz brauchbar funktionieren. Nokia hat da wohl offensichtlich Ähnliches im Sinn, in diesem Geobereich da führen zu sein. Bloß das ist dann sozusagen alles im wesentlichen Verkehr. Wenn man jetzt solche Daten von diesen Unternehmen kauft, wie erhält man die denn? Also was bekommt man? Ist das ein Zugriff auf deren Server? Oder schicken die einem dann auch irgendwie eine CD rum?
Also die schicken dir dann schon eine CD oder DVD oder sowas. Und in der Regel kaufst du von denen nicht einmalig, sondern du machst gleich so eine Art Update-Vertrag. Du kriegst die einmalig und du kriegst dann irgendwie einmal im halben Jahr oder sowas ein Update.
Eine Subskription sozusagen.
Allerdings ist es, also wenn du jetzt da anrufst und sagst hier, ich bin Tim Pritlove, ich würde mal gerne mich dafür interessieren, von euch so eine CD zu kaufen, dann sag ich erst mal, wer bist du überhaupt? Also die verkaufen nicht einfach an jeden ihre Daten, sondern dann musst du schon so ein bisschen, musst schon sozusagen berechtigtes Interesse haben, dass die überhaupt mit dir reden. Die arbeiten auch relativ viel mit Resellern zusammen. Also gerade wenn es eben dann an diesen Endkundenmarkt rangeht, da eben der Endkunde kauft normalerweise, der kleinere Kunde kauft nicht direkt bei Naftek oder Teleatlas irgendwas ein, sondern da gibt es eine ganze Anzahl von größeren Resellern oder auch Datenanreicher, die dann wiederum selber, die dann sagen, ich kaufe hier von Naftek und von Teleatlas Daten und dann bereite ich die noch ein bisschen auf oder mische noch irgendwas rein und dann schnüre ich daraus so kleine Pakete und verkaufe die dann an Endkunden weiter. Da gibt es dann Firmen, die haben sich speziell auf, also es gibt zum Beispiel Firmen, die machen diesen Job für Navigationssystemhersteller. Das heißt, als Navigationssystemhersteller kannst du dann auch sagen, ich gehe zu so einer Firma, die für mich das schon alles managt mit den Updates und so weiter und so weiter und von denen kriege ich dann einfach nur noch eine CD, die genau in dem Format ist, wie ich es für mein System brauche.
Das heißt, es gibt auch eine Vielzahl an Formaten.
Ja, die Geräte arbeiten alle mit irgendwelchen proprietären Formaten. Die Daten kommen von Naftech und Tela Atlas in der Regel in einem Format, das nennt sich GDF. Das ist ein ganz, ganz altertümliches, obskures ASCII-Format von so einer Art mit fester Satzlänge. Das ASCII mit fester Satzlänge oder pro Zeile irgendwie, ab Spalte 40 steht dann der Straßenname immer bis Spalte 55 und wenn er länger ist, dann steht der Rest ab Spalte 137. Und irgendwie so, dieses GDF-Format ist ein ganz riesen, von einem Industriekonsortium erstelltes Format, mit Autoherstellern und Siemens und Co., alle mit von der Partie und ein sehr altes Format. Aber in diesem Format geben die normal die Daten raus, mit diversen, wenn das ein bisschen interessant ist.
Und es handelt sich dabei um Vektordaten oder was, also ich meine, was wird beschrieben? Also ich frage mich halt immer so, allein so was wie eine Autobahn, ja? Also was bekomme ich da, bekomme ich so einen Vektor-Umriss von den Kanten?
Das GDF ist ein sehr, sehr kompliziertes Format, das hat mehrere Layer, wird auf einem, sozusagen ganz grob gesagt, kannst du dir so vorstellen, auf einem ganz, auf einem Grund liegenden Layer wird erstmal beschrieben, ok, da ist so ein Stück Beton, da ist so ein bisschen Beton in der Landschaft. Und auf einem darüber liegenden Layer wird dann beschrieben, auf diesem Stück Beton gibt es jetzt drei Fahrspuren in die Richtung und drei Fahrspuren in die andere Richtung und die rechte davon ist aber die Spur, die man nur nimmt, wenn man abbiegen will. Und auf einem noch darüber liegenden Layer kann dann beschrieben werden, dass da bestimmte Tempolimits für bestimmte Spuren gelten und so weiter und so weiter. Also es gibt da sozusagen drei Schichten in diesem GDF-Modell, die sozusagen unterschiedliche Abstraktionsgrade beschreiben. Es ist relativ komplex, es ist auch ein Format, das zwar mittlerweile ein ISO-Standard ist und deswegen theoretisch kann man das auch, die Dokumente dazu bekommen. Es ist also kein richtig geschlossenes Format, aber so richtig offen ist es auch nicht, also dass man sich das einfach so runterladen könnte und selbst wenn man an die Beschreibung rankommt, gibt es keine offene Software, die damit umgehen kann. Das heißt, es ist immer so ein bisschen so ein frickeliges Format. Aber das ist das, was du da bekommst und das ist dann halt auch der Bereich, wo dann viele von diesen Datenaufbereiterfirmen sich so ein bisschen etabliert haben, dass die sagen, wir nehmen diese Daten und die sind alle so ein bisschen komisch und vor allem Tele, Atlas und Navtech sprechen auch einen ganz leichten Unterschied dieses GDF. Also das unterscheidet sich dann in Details und dann gibt es dann halt Unternehmen, die das dann aufbereiten für die Kartografie oder für die Navigation oder wieder andere, die sich darauf spezialisiert haben, dass da vielleicht bestimmte Sachen draus zu extrahieren oder sowas.
Und das Koordinatensystem, was zum Einsatz kommt, ist GPS? Oder ist das nochmal eine andere Geschichte?
Das ist jetzt, also da muss man jetzt, das kann man jetzt so nicht stehen lassen, das Koordinatensystem ist GPS. Das ist ein bisschen, also das sind normalerweise Längen und Breiten, gerade in denen die arbeiten, ja. Und in der, also WGS 84, das gleiche, was GPS auch benutzt, ja, als Referenzsystem, ja.
Und ist das dann auch mit Höhe oder sind das in der Regel dann auch wirklich nur so zweidimensionale Informationen, wenn man einen Berg haben will, muss man nochmal extra kaufen?
Ehrlich gesagt, das weiß ich nicht. Also es gibt bei dem, beim GDF, das GDF selber enthält glaube ich keine Höhen-Daten, aber die, diese, diese Veredelungsfirmen, die verwenden glaube ich auch teilweise einfach digitale Geländemodelle, die sie aus einer anderen Quelle dazu kaufen, um dann eine Straße halt auf diese, auf diese Oberfläche drauf zu projizieren und dadurch zu sagen, ok, gut, an dieser Stelle ist die Straße offensichtlich so und so hoch. Das heißt, du kannst diese Daten schon bekommen, aber soweit ich weiß, sind die original von Naftek und Teleatlas nicht mit Höhen versehen.
Ja, also mit anderen Worten, es ist entweder alles sehr teuer, beziehungsweise es ist auch schwierig zu verarbeiten und man kann vor allem nicht machen, was man will. Das ist so ein Grundproblem der Ist-Situation.
Und wenn mal ein Fehler drin ist, was machst du denn dann? Also irgendwo sind die Daten falsch. Du kannst da Naftek und Teleatlas haben, bei beide irgendwelche Webinterfaces, wo du solche Fehlermeldungen reinkippen kannst und dann kannst du, wenn du Glück hast, dauert es dann nach einem Jahr oder so was, die Daten dann mal wieder aktualisiert. Ich meine, TomTom hat ja dieses, es gibt da sowas, das heißt TomTom Map Share. Da kannst du auf den moderneren TomTom-Geräten in begrenztem Maße die Daten korrigieren, dass du sagst, diese Tankstelle ist aber eigentlich 300 Meter weiter hinten oder sowas. Und dann kann es auch zwischen den verschiedenen TomTom-Usern irgendwie über das Internet verteilt werden, diese Information. Aber das ist ganz, ganz begrenzt und du kannst da nicht irgendwie sagen, ah, hier ist übrigens ein Neubaugebiet und hier gibt es jetzt eine neue Straße oder die Straße hier heißt falsch oder so.
Ja, das heißt, im Prinzip dieser Trend, Leute mit einzubeziehen, der kommt auf. Also bei Google gehört, bei TomTom, andere Systeme werden sicherlich nachziehen. Ob das jetzt eine direkte Folge auf OpenStreetMap ist, keine Ahnung. Letzten Endes ist es ja auch, wenn man ein bisschen darüber nachdenkt, alles sehr naheliegend, so ein System, weil die Welt da draußen ändert sich halt auch am laufenden Meter an. Eigentlich müsste man ja sowieso zu den 3D-Daten noch eine Vierte hinzufügen, eine Zeitachse, das weiß nicht, wie ist denn das, wenn man diese Daten bekommt? Ist da in diesem GDF sozusagen auch eine Information, wie alt diese Information ist? Oder ist das sozusagen dann der Poststempel, mit dem die CD angeliefert wird?
Also ich vermute fast, dass so eine Information da nicht drin ist, weil ich vermute, dass das dann so ein bisschen peinlich wäre, wenn jemand das analysiert.
Das wollen sie gar nicht wissen. Und ist das bei OpenStreetMap so?
Bei OpenStreetMap kannst du immer sehen, wann ein Objekt zuletzt geändert wurde oder auch, wann es erfasst wurde. Aber weißt natürlich nicht, ob der, der das aufgrund von welcher Information jemand jetzt was verändert hat. Oder wie gut derjenige wirklich informiert war, der da was geändert hat. Ob der jetzt ein exaktes GPS gehabt hat, mit dem er was gemessen hat oder einfach nur aus dem Fenster geguckt hat und gesagt hat, das sieht ungefähr so aus und solche Sachen. Also...
Na gut, auf den Punkt kommen wir nochmal. Jetzt, nach dieser langen Vorrede, sollten wir vielleicht nochmal kurz das Projekt als solches nochmal vorstellen. Vor allem für die Leute, die eigentlich noch überhaupt nicht so richtig wissen, worum es dabei genau geht. Wann ist OpenStreetMap von wem initiiert worden und wie hat sich das entwickelt?
OpenStreetMap ist 2004 von Steve Krauss gegründet worden in England. Der hatte irgendeine Anwendung, wo er eine Karte für brauchte. Und er konnte halt keine bekommen zu irgendwie vernünftigen Preisen und in irgendeiner freien Form, dass er mit was anfangen konnte. Dann hat er gesagt, okay, dann mache ich es halt selber. Und hat sich sein GPS-Gerät geschnappt und ist irgendwie ein bisschen durch die Lande gelaufen. Und hat es so losgetreten. Und dann ist es langsam von ihm aus gewachsen. Er ist überall rumgezogen, hat allen Leuten erzählt, wie toll seine Idee ist. Wann war das? 2004 war die Gründung.
2004 hatte er dieses Problem.
Im Sommer 2004.
Also gerade mal fünf Jahre her.
Und ist dann rumgezogen, hat allen Leuten erzählt, was für eine tolle Idee er da hat. Und viele Leute haben das auch so gesehen, dass die Idee gut ist. Und dann ist das Projekt am Anfang erst sehr langsam natürlich gewachsen. Aber das ging relativ schnell, ja. Noch keine fünf Jahre alt, das Projekt, dass immer mehr Leute gesehen haben, ja, das macht wirklich Sinn. Und auf die Art und Weise kann man wirklich Daten erfassen. Das ist ja bei OpenStreetMap so, dass man wirklich mit einem GPS-Gerät draußen rumläuft oder meistens rumfährt. Die meisten Leute machen es vom Fahrrad aus. Endlich mal eine Gelegenheit auch so für den Computergeek mal von der, von einem heimischen Computer wegzukommen und ein bisschen Sport zu treiben. Man fährt rum im GPS-Gerät, die natürlich auch nicht beliebig genau sind und macht daraus irgendwie eine Karte so von Hand irgendwie gebastelt und es kommt natürlich immer die Kritik von Leuten, dass das ja gar nicht funktionieren kann. Das Landesvermessungsamt oder das Katasteramt oder so, wenn die eine Vermessung machen, ist die irgendwie zentimetergenau. Und das können wir hier natürlich nicht haben. Aber das ist auch gar nicht nötig unbedingt. Die meisten Karten funktionieren wunderbar gut und es ist völlig ausreichend, wenn man die plus, minus 5 Meter oder so genaue Karte GPS-Geräte hat. Und so hat es relativ schnell funktioniert, dass man mal so klein angefangen hat. Man hat mal gesagt, okay, wir erfassen einfach mal Straßen. Der Name OpenStreetMap kommt ja auch daher, dass man zuerst halt erstmal die Straßen erfasst hat und gar nicht dran gedacht hat, was da alles noch draus werden kann. Und heute erfassen wir viel mehr als nur die Straßen.
Jetzt vielleicht nochmal so zum eigentlichen Gründungsmoment. Also welche Infrastruktur hat denn der Steve überhaupt erst mal geschaffen, damit sich da etwas entwickeln konnte? Also was, ich meine, er hat ja jetzt nicht einfach nur gesagt, das existiert jetzt und dann wuchs auf einmal aus dem Internet so eine Karte heraus. Welche Komponenten braucht man denn erst mal, um so einen Sammelvorgang loszutreten? Also was gab es?
Also als erstes braucht man irgendwas, um diese GPS-Tracks zu sammeln. Also das GPS-Gerät zeichnet auf, wo es langgefahren ist quasi. Und diese Informationen muss man sammeln und in irgendeiner Form darstellen können, weil das ist die Basis dann, diese Spuren, die man da aufgezeichnet hat, quasi ist die Basis für die Karte. Man braucht irgendeine Form von zentraler Datenbank, in der diese GPS-Tracks einerseits gesammelt werden können und in der dann auch die Kartenobjekte, die man dann basierend auf diesen GPS-Tracks erzeugt, gespeichert werden können.
Das heißt, die eigentliche Teilnahme besteht darin, dass man irgendwo langgeht. Und dann zieht man so eine Spur hinter sich her und die wird in diesem Gerät gesammelt. Und diese Spur als solche, ohne irgendwelche Metainformationen, worum es sich dabei handelt, einfach nur so, da bin ich gewesen, die legt man erstmal in eine Datenbank.
Genau, das ist der erste Schritt. Das ist nicht unbedingt notwendig, die in eine Datenbank zu legen. Kann man aber machen und ist auch im OpenStreetMap-Projekt allgemein üblich. Das hat zwei Gründe. Erstmal können andere Leute dann diese Spuren benutzen. Und zum Beispiel, wenn ihr eigenes GPS-Gerät nicht so genau war oder sowas, die die Spuren von anderen Leuten benutzen oder ergänzen. Man kann sich gegenseitig ergänzen. Und es dient auch dazu, zu dokumentieren, dass man diese Straßen wirklich lang gelaufen ist. Sodass wenn jemand später kommt und sagt, ihr habt aber meine Karte kopiert, dann kann man sagen, ne, stimmt nicht, guck mal, ich bin da wirklich lang gefahren. Das ist also auch ein Aspekt dabei, warum man diese Tracks...
Also beweisen, in einigen Sinne ist es nicht, aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein deutliches Indizier.
Also was man dann noch braucht, was zu dieser Startinfrastruktur auch dazu gehörte, ist eine Editor-Software, mit der man dann eben auf diesen Tracks obendrauf praktisch so Straßen einmalen kann und sagen kann, ok, diese Straße hier, das ist jetzt eine Wohnstraße und die heißt so und so. Da hatte der Steve ein Java-Applet gemacht am Anfang, dass das konnte. Deswegen mussten auch die Tracks am Anfang, heute ist das nicht mehr so, anfangs mussten die Tracks alle auf den zentralen Server, weil das Java-Applet nur diese Tracks vom zentralen Server anzeigen konnte.
Verstehe.
Heute kann man mit den Editoren auch sagen, lad mal hier von meiner Platte das File und so. Und dazu musste dann natürlich auch noch irgendwas, was in irgendeiner Form, wo man praktisch den Erfolg sehen konnte, wo man irgendwie eine Karte anzeigen konnte. Und da bin ich ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen überfragt, was sie da ganz am Anfang hatten. Da gab es, es gab eine Webseite, die die Karte angezeigt hat.
Das waren aber immer nur die GPS-Tracks, die man am Anfang sehen konnte. Man hat also nicht eine wirkliche Karte sehen können, sondern es wurden nur die GPS-Tracks übereinander angezeigt. Und daraus hat sich dann so ein grobes Bild ergeben, wo man erahnen konnte, wo so die Straßen sind, sage ich jetzt mal. Aber das war keine Karte in dem Sinne, wie wir das heute haben.
Das heißt, der eigentliche Weg, der von Anfang an sozusagen, so wie es gestartet wurde, ist es im Prinzip im Wesentlichen, bis auf ein paar Details immer noch, man erfasst Tracks, man lädt sie hoch oder man bearbeitet sie einfach in einem Editor, also lokal oder eben von einem zentralen Speicher heraus, nimmt sie sich und malt dann quasi so ein bisschen rüber, wie in so einem Kindermahlbuch und sagt, hier ist, aber hier ist jetzt was. Wie mache ich das? Wie zeichne ich jetzt eine Straße ein? Also nimmt man dann die Mitte oder nimmt man dann die Kante oder sowohl als auch? Also welche Elemente einer Straße muss ich denn überhaupt benennen, um klar zu machen, was diese Straße für eine Präsenz in der realen Welt hat?
Ja, also bei einer Straße ist es relativ einfach. Man zeichnet die Mittellinie ein, so als Vektor, wie man das von einem Vektor-Grafikprogramm kennt, quasi. Man hat eine Linie und dann gibt man diesem Linienobjekt, was man da erzeugt hat, zusätzliche Informationen, um zu sagen, dies ist jetzt eine Straße, dies ist eine Einbahnstraße, dies ist eine Durchgangsstraße, also Bundesstraße oder eine Wohnstraße. Solche Informationen. Es gibt verschiedene Objekte. Bei Straßen ist es ein Linienobjekt. Es gibt auch Punktobjekte natürlich. Wenn ich einen Briefkasten einzeichne, dann ist das einfach ein Punkt, der dann diese Informationen bekommt. Und natürlich gibt es auch eine Form von Flächenobjekten. Wenn ich jetzt sagen will, das ist ein Park oder das ist ein Gebäude oder sowas, dann kann ich das als Fläche eintragen. Und man hat diese grundlegenden Geometrieobjekte erstmal. Bei uns bei OpenStreetMap sind das zwei grundlegende Objekte. Das sind die Nodes. Ein Node ist ein Punkt, der eine Position irgendwo hat. Und dann gibt es die Ways, die verbinden mehrere Punkte miteinander. Das ist quasi ein Straßenlauf und so was. Und daraus ergibt sich dann ein Straßennetz. Und die ganzen Ways sich zusammenstückelen. Und die Fläche? Und die Fläche, dafür gibt es aus historischen Gründen etwas merkwürdig. Aber es gibt kein eigenes Objekt. So eine Fläche ist einfach ein Way, der geschlossen ist. Und der dann bestimmte Zusatzinformationen eben bekommt. Wir nennen das Tags. Man kann an jedes Objekt, kann man beliebige Tags dranhängen. Tags haben immer das Format key gleich value. Und wenn ein Tag, jetzt zum Beispiel ein Park, der wird als Leisure gleich Park eingetragen, dann erkennt man daran, dass es eine Fläche sein muss. Eine Straße, zum Beispiel eine Wohnstraße, wäre jetzt Highway gleich Residential. Das würde ausdrücken, dass dieser Way, den man da gezeichnet hat, eine Wohnstraße ist. Eine Bundesstraße wäre Highway Primary, die Namen kommen natürlich alle aus dem Englischen.
Das muss man so eintippen, oder was?
Das muss man natürlich nicht mehr eintippen inzwischen. Am Anfang war das so, dass man das alles eintippen muss. Es ist auch noch gar nicht so lange her, dass man das alles eintippen und wissen musste, wie diese Sachen genau heißen. Heutzutage ist es so in den Editoren natürlich, dass man ein Menü hat und dann einfach, man hat seinen Weg dahin geklickt und dann sucht man aus dem Menü aus und sagt, okay, das ist jetzt eine Straße und man möchte jetzt da jetzt eine Straße draus machen, dann kriegt man eine entsprechende Anzeige, wo man auch sagen kann, okay, das soll jetzt zusätzlich ankreuzen, Einbahnstraße sein und hier bitte den Namen eintragen und da vielleicht noch die Nummer, dass es jetzt die B17 ist oder irgendwas. Inzwischen ist das alles so, dass man das im Editor eintragen kann. Es ist aber ganz wichtig in dem Projekt, dass es immer noch die Möglichkeit gibt, auch beliebige andere Tags einzutragen. Es gibt keine definitive abschließende Liste, welche Tags sind überhaupt erlaubt sind. Die Welt ist komplizierter, als dass man sie klassifizieren könnte in schöne kleine Teile aufteilen und sagen, es gibt hier diese 17 Straßentypen. Dann ist es getan, dann kommt irgendjemand an und sagt, ich habe hier aber so einen Straßentyp, der ist ein bisschen ähnlich wie der, aber eigentlich anders und ich möchte irgendwas anders machen. Dann hat er diese Möglichkeit. Deswegen ist es wichtig, dass man weiß, dass diese Möglichkeit existiert, dass man auch über diese Vorgaben, die der Editor vielleicht macht, hinaus weitere Informationen erfassen kann. Das ist auch das, was das Projekt voranbringt, dass Leute immer wieder neue Tags erfinden und neue Arten von Sachen auch erfassen.
Überwachungs-Kameras.
Zum Beispiel.
Das ist einmal das, was das Projekt voranbringt. Auf der anderen Seite ist es aber auch ein ganz, ganz großes, immer wehrendes Thema, gerade für die Neueinsteiger, die damit oft nicht klarkommen. Ich mache mir gerne Feinde damit, dass ich sage, in Deutschland ganz besonders. Ich habe den Eindruck, dass aus Deutschland öfter die Kritik kommt, dass das alles so ungeordnet und chaotisch ist und überhaupt nicht organisiert ist.
Woher sonst?
Aus anderen Ländern. Also Leute, die einfach kommen und sagen, ja, wie wollt ihr denn damit jemals ein gescheites Routing machen? Ihr habt ja gar nicht fest definiert, was es für Straßentypen gibt. Das kann ja nie funktionieren. Oder wie wollt ihr denn? Also einmal das, dass die Leute sagen, das Schema, es muss von vornherein, wir nennen es mal eine Ontologie, es muss von vornherein ein genaues Schema da sein, welche 15 Straßenklassen es gibt und was das ganz genau bedeutet. Sodass der Mapper, es ist für die Deutschen besonders wichtig, dass es immer einen genau richtigen Weg gibt, wie man es macht. Ich stehe vor einer Straße, dann brauche ich meinen Kriterienkatalog, anhand dem ich dann abhaken kann am Ende. Wenn ich das abgehakt habe, dann komme ich zum Ergebnis, aha, diese Straße muss, um es korrekt zu machen, damit mich auch nachher niemand kritisieren kann, genau so eingetragen werden. Und genau so läuft das eben nicht in OpenStreetMap, sondern OpenStreetMap ist immer so ein bisschen der Mapper vor Ort, hat immer das Sagen, wenn der Mapper meint, also diese Straße ist zwar so eigentlich, es ist zwar keine Bundesstraße und so, aber für dieses Dorf hat diese Straße eine extrem hohe Bedeutung und ist die Hauptdurchfahrtstraße und so, dann darf die schon mal eine Klasse höher getact werden als das normalerweise. Oder ist das dann ganz, ganz üblich? Und damit kommen viele Leute nicht so klar mit diesem. Und dann gibt es auch immer diese Kritik, dass das ganze Jahr gar nicht systematisch, nach dem Motto, wieso macht ihr euch Gedanken über die Erfassung der Lampenpfähle in dem Ort so und so, wenn ihr doch noch nicht mal das Autobahnnetz komplett habt? Ist doch blödsinnig, was seid ihr denn für Idioten? Macht doch erstmal die wichtigen Sachen fertig. Und da muss man immer sagen, wichtig ist halt das, was der Einzelne wichtig findet.
Man könnte jetzt auch mit Hundemülltüten-Spender Berlin verzeichnen. Da hätte ich jetzt auch großes Interesse dran, würde mir jetzt auch mehr weiterhelfen als die Autobahn in Baden-Württemberg. Klar, das ist immer alles relativ. Das heißt, es ist jetzt nicht so ein von oben verordnetes Ordnungssystem, sondern es ist eigentlich eher so ein selbstorganisierendes Chaos. Kann man das mal so grob festhalten?
Kann man so sagen, das trifft das eigentlich sehr, sehr gut. Selbstorganisiertes Chaos. Manche Sachen sind schon relativ klar. Da hat sich mit der Zeit rausgebildet, wie gewisse Sachen zu machen sind. Und das machen dann alle so. Und bei anderen Sachen gibt es verschiedene Fraktionen. Der eine macht so, der andere macht so. Und verschiedene Leute haben verschiedene Ideen, wie es am besten ist. Und mit der Zeit bilden sich dann schon so Gemeinsamkeiten raus. Und es ist natürlich auch so, dass alle wollen, dass das, was sie einzeichnen, das nachher auch auf der Karte erscheint. Wenn ihr dann nachher im Web guckt, dann ist da ja eine Karte. Und da möchte ich ja, dass dann mein Hundekottütenspender da drauf ist, wenn ich mir viel Mühe gegeben habe, den einzuzeichnen. Und deswegen ist da eine gewisse Regulierung noch drin in diesem Chaos, weil natürlich nicht alles auf der Karte erscheinen kann. Und die Leute, die festlegen, was auf der Karte erscheint, einen gewissen Einfluss darauf haben, wie Sachen einzutragen sind, damit sie richtig auf der Karte erscheinen. Das betrifft jetzt vielleicht nicht die Klassifizierung der Straßen, weil das kann der natürlich nicht sehen, ob das richtig war, die Straße so oder so zu erfassen. Aber welche Sachen überhaupt auf der Karte erscheinen, das kann natürlich der Festlegen, der die Karte nachher macht.
Ich habe am Anfang schon so ein bisschen diesen Vergleich zu Wikipedia bemüht. Wenn ich das jetzt so höre, dann erscheint mir der noch sehr viel naheliegender. Da ja auch dort am Anfang in dem Sinne überhaupt gar keine Struktur war. Oder teilweise ist ja auch heute noch so. Man schreibt halt einfach irgendeinen Text rein. Und da gab es erstmal noch keine Strukturen. Und dann haben sich eben über die Zeit bestimmte Konventionen durchgesetzt, weil die eben einfach von mehreren Leuten als sinnvoll erachtet wurden. Andere Leute haben dann diese Konventionen übernommen. Und daraus hat sich dann eben über die Zeit so eine Struktur entwickelt. Wenn man heute sich die Wikipedia anschaut, wird man ja in manchen Artikeln, also ich bin erschlagen, von was für Kategorie-Sidebars und sonstige Systematik-Listen und Tabellenformate und so weiter dabei zutage kommen. Greift dieser Vergleich oder ist er auch teilweise irreführend?
Also der Vergleich ist sicher sehr gut für viele Sachen. Stimmt es auf jeden Fall. Man kann bei OpenStreetMap ganz klar diese Entwicklung auch sehen, von dem am Anfang hier free for all, jeder kann irgendwie was machen und keiner weiß eigentlich so richtig. Und wie dann schrittweise mehr und mehr Sachen festgelegt werden und auch mehr und mehr Detail geschaffen werden. Und das, was du jetzt gerade für die Wikipedia beschrieben hast mit irgendwelchen Sidebars und so weiter, das gibt es bei OpenStreetMap in ähnlicher Form sozusagen. Früher hat man nur gesagt, wir sind froh, dass wir ob die Straße eingetragen haben, den Namen von der Straße haben. Und heute wollen wir die Geschwindigkeitsbeschränkung haben und sagen, ah, unter Rechtzeit ist noch ein Fahrradweg und es ist eine Einbahnstraße, aber Fahrräder dürfen auch in die andere Richtung. Und hier ist noch die Brücke und Durchfahrtsbeschränkung, die ist nicht so hoch. Und also diese ganzen zusätzlichen Informationen, was man auch alles machen kann, wird immer detaillierter auch erfasst. Was bei der Wikipedia anders ist oder ein bisschen anders ist, Wikipedia-Artikel stehen erstmal für sich selber. Die haben natürlich Verbindungen zu anderen Wikipedia-Artikeln, aber ein Artikel hat schon eine gewisse Einheit. Bei OpenStreetMap ist das so ein bisschen schwierig, weil die einzelne Straße oder sowas ist zu klein, um irgendeine Einheit zu sein. Wenn alles zusammenhängt in dieser riesengroßen Karte, wenn ich an einer Stelle anfange zu ziehen, dann habe ich nachher die ganze Karte in der Hand, weil alles zusammenhängt in diesem großen Blob. Also es gibt durchaus erhebliche Unterschiede zur Wikipedia auch. Diese Sache macht es zum Beispiel schwierig. Mit dieser Versionierung bei OpenStreetMap ist es auch so wie bei Wikipedia, dass sie alle alten Versionen aufheben. Jede Änderung wird mitgeloggt, wer wann welche Änderung gemacht hat. Aber es ist viel schwieriger, zu einer vorigen Version zurückzuklären, weil eben alles zusammenhängt. Wenn ich eine Sache auf die vorige Version zurückstelle, dann sind die Sachen drum herum, hängen dann irgendwo in der Luft.
Und Änderungen basieren dann unter Umständen auch wiederum auf anderen Sachen, dass irgendwas genauer positioniert wird von Hand, weil jetzt eine andere Information vorliegt, die man so vorher nicht hatte oder so?
Zum Beispiel ja. Also es ist ein ganz natürliches Vorgehen, dass ich vielleicht irgendeinen Weg abgefahren bin und nur den Weg selber eingetragen habe. Und ein bisschen später kommt dann einer und sieht, ah, da ist es so ein bisschen ungenau gewesen, zupft es so ein bisschen zurecht. Und der Fahrradweg, der parallel zur Straße verleucht, war vielleicht nicht als einzelner Fahrradweg eingetragen und macht den auch noch dazu. Und dann ist da eine Kreuzung. Da hat man vielleicht am Anfang einfach zwei sich querende Linien gehabt und einen Punkt in der Mitte, der die beiden Linien verbindet. Und jetzt macht man aber noch die Abbiegespuren mit rein und verfeinert die ganze Kreuzung, dass man genauer sieht, was da passiert. Und das passiert ständig. Das ist ein ganz wichtiges Teil des OpenStreetMap-Projektes, dass man nicht irgendwie wartet, bis man irgendwas perfekt machen kann, sondern man legt einfach los. Man macht einfach, was man kann, macht was einen interessiert und was man kann, was man mit seinen Mitteln machen kann. Der eine hat vielleicht ein besseres GPS als der andere, dann kann er hinterher die Sachen genauer machen. Aber erst mal loslegen und dann Stück für Stück verfeinern. Und jeder kann auch alles ändern. Auch das ist wie bei der Wikipedia. Jeder kann alle Daten von allen anderen Leuten ändern, kann alles wieder löschen, kann alles ergänzen usw.
Nur mal so zwischendurch. Auch die Lizenz ist vergleichbar mittlerweile. Alle Daten, die jetzt eingepflegt werden, stehen unter welcher Lizenz?
Creative Commons Share Like, Attribution Share Like 2.0.
Die kann man jetzt vielleicht auch mal erklären, was die jetzt genau besagt?
Also das mit der Lizenz, da könnte man sicherlich so ein eigenes Podcast machen, aber ich lasse das noch ganz kurz zusammenfassen. Also Creative Commons Attribution Share Like, das bedeutet, jeder, der die Daten aus OpenStreetMap nimmt und für irgendwas benutzt, muss drunter schreiben, dass sie von OpenStreetMap sind. Und wenn er irgendwas veröffentlicht, was mit diesen Daten, was sozusagen ein abgeleitetes Werk aus diesen Daten ist, dann muss dieses abgeleitete Werk auch unter der Creative Commons Attribution Share Like Lizenz stehen. Das bedeutet, wenn jetzt einer die Daten nimmt und einen schönen Atlas druckt, macht sich sehr viel Arbeit, koloriert das noch so ein bisschen von Hand nach und so, druckt dann einen schönen Atlas, ist kein Problem. Er darf diesen Atlas auch dann von einem Verlag drucken lassen und für 100 Euro im Buchhandel verkaufen. Er muss diesen Atlas niemanden kostenlos geben oder als PDF zum Runterladen anbieten oder so.
Und da muss auch niemanden Geld dafür geben.
Er muss auch niemanden Geld dafür geben. Er muss nur draufschreiben, die Daten sind aus OpenStreetMap und dieser Atlas steht unter Creative Commons Share Like 2.0. Und das bedeutet dann wiederum, dass jeder andere diesen Atlas natürlich beliebig kopieren darf zum Beispiel. Also der Verlag in China darf sich dann diesen Atlas nehmen und darf den Faximile davon machen und den halt für 20 Euro in den Buchhandel bringen oder wie auch immer. Also das ist sozusagen, man darf immer, man darf die Daten nehmen, man darf damit alles machen, nur man darf dann, wenn man ein Produkt herstellt, das muss dann eben wieder unter dieser gleichen freien Lizenz stehen. Da gibt es ein paar Schwierigkeiten immer, wenn man diese Daten mischt mit anderen Daten. Also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel angenommen, ich würde jetzt meinen Atlas herstellen wollen und würde, weil aber mir an einigen, sagen wir mal, weil das Tankstellennetz in OpenStreetMap noch nicht so komplett ist, da kaufe ich mir die Liste aller Tankstellen von Tela Atlas hinzu und drucke die noch in meinen Atlas da rein. Tela Atlas gibt mir aber keine beliebige Lizenz, sondern die sagt, ja, das ist aber nur hier für Atlas-Auflage maximal 1000 Stück oder irgendwie sowas. Da bin ich dann der Bridulier, das geht dann nicht, weil ich kann nicht meinen gedruckten Atlas rausgeben und kann sagen, okay, der ist share-like bis auf die Tankstellen, weil ich ja ein Produkt geschaffen habe, in dem was beides untrennbar miteinander vermischt ist. Und da gibt es immer mal wieder Schwierigkeiten, dass auch zum Beispiel, dass jemand sagt, ich habe hier von meinem lokalen Verkehrsverbund deren Verkehrsnetz bekommen auf CD für ein akademisches Projekt an meiner Uni mit der Auflage nur zu Forschungszwecken oder sowas. Und jetzt vermische ich das mit OpenStreetMap-Daten und mache da irgendwie eine tolle Animation draus, wo man dann sieht, wie Busse auf Straßen lang fahren oder was auch immer, irgendein Produkt. Das tue ich dann irgendwo auf die Uni-Webseite und dann schreibe ich drunter, ist aber nur zu Forschungszwecken freigegeben. Das geht halt nicht. ShareLag, Creative Commons Attribution, ShareLag 2.0. Das heißt, das Produkt ist nicht nur zu Forschungszwecken, sondern es ist einfach für jeden, für alles. Und da muss man ein bisschen aufpassen.
Ja, ich denke, so weit wollte ich es jetzt vertiefen, weil ich wollte jetzt auch noch nicht vollständig wegkommen von diesem eigentlichen Erfassungsding und auch noch mal ein bisschen, um noch mal ein bisschen genauer auch noch mal rauszuarbeiten, welche Daten man wirklich erarbeitet. Ich meine, wir hatten das so mit den Trecks und so, man kann jetzt alle möglichen Metadaten machen. Ich meine, diese Metadaten in dem Moment, wo man sie sozusagen verwendet, dann schafft man damit quasi einen reservierten Namensraum. Oder gibt es auch miteinander in Konflikt stehende Tags? Gibt es irgendwie eine Ordnung dafür, wie Dinge jetzt benannt werden oder erfinde ich die einfach selber? Also wie tagge ich jetzt zum Beispiel meine Hundekot-Mülltüten-Spender-Dinger? Muss ich da einen Antrag stellen oder denke ich mir da einfach irgendwas aus?
Da denkst du dir einfach irgendwas aus und überlegst dir, wie das heißen soll und schreibst es da rein. Da muss man niemanden fragen, das kann man einfach in seinen Editor eintippen und dann ist es da drin.
Kann aber sein, dass jetzt andere auch schon angefangen haben, dieselbe Sache zu machen.
Kann sein, dass jemand was Ähnliches gemacht hat. Es gibt auch immer wieder Leute, die Tags dann erfinden, die irgendwie ID oder Info oder irgendwas heißen. Und keiner weiß, was damit gemeint ist. Jeder versteht da was anderes. Da das natürlich nicht sinnvoller ist, heißt man versucht...
Sie sind dann sozusagen miteinander in Konflikt stehen. Das ist nicht das Problem, worauf ich hinaus wollte.
Also man versucht natürlich, wenn man das macht, guckt man sich typischerweise an, wie andere Tags heißen. Und es gibt da schon gewisse Konventionen, sag ich jetzt mal, wie man Sachen machen kann. Das ist aber immer ein individueller Fall, wo man sich überlegen muss, was denn jetzt passt. Und man versucht natürlich einen Namen zu vergeben, der möglichst klar und möglichst eindeutig ist. Aber es gibt diese Konflikte. Und wir haben auch durchaus Namen, wo man im Nachhinein vielleicht sagen muss, das hätte man vielleicht anders nennen sollen, das klingt so ein bisschen falsch oder sowas. Und es ist aber auch so, dass es teilweise korrigiert wird. Es ist ja so, wir haben eine zentrale Datenbank. Das heißt, jeder kann auch jederzeit hingehen und kann sagen, gib mir alles, was einen bestimmten Tag hat, und kann das wieder ändern. Man muss vielleicht einen kleinen Skript dazu schreiben, was das automatisiert macht. Deswegen ist es auch gar nicht so tragisch, wenn der eine irgendwas so genannt hat und der andere irgendwas so genannt. Es gibt zum Beispiel die Wanderrouten. Da gibt es manche Leute, die nennen das Route Hiking. Andere sagen Route Walking. Da gibt es im Moment verschiedene Namen. Das muss natürlich irgendwann mal vereinheitigt werden, damit nicht jede Software wissen muss, dass es unter diesen drei verschiedenen Sachen irgendwas geben kann.
Aber ist schon immer alles englisch?
Es ist fast immer englisch, weil das Projekt kommt erstens natürlich aus England. Dadurch hatten die so einen gewissen Vorsprung. Aber es ist natürlich auch deswegen so, weil Englisch doch die internationale Sprache ist, die von vielen verstanden wird. Wenn wir aber jetzt einen Tag erfinden, das nur in Deutschland irgendeine Bedeutung hat, dann kommt es durchaus vor, dass man dann auch einen deutschen Namen benutzt dafür. Das würde man zum Beispiel dann machen, wir hatten neulich, die Geschichte haben wir Kreisgrenzen importiert. Und da gibt es eine Gemeindenumerierung hier in Deutschland, wo jede Gemeinde eine Nummer hat und ich weiß gar nicht mehr, welchen Tag wir davon wendet haben. Aber der hat jetzt einen deutschen Namen, weil das was ist, was außerhalb Deutschlands nicht existiert. Und jemand, der nicht hier in Deutschland ist, interessiert das sowieso nicht.
Es handelt sich um eine spezifisch deutsche Information.
Ja.
Das ist wahrscheinlich bei Hundekot-Müll-Tüten-Spender genauso.
Es ist manchmal interessant, weil die Deutschen natürlich immer gerne nach den Regeln spielen wollen. Und wenn die dann sich irgendwas finden und sagen, wir müssten das entdecken, dann ist ja immer die ewige Diskussion unter lauter Leuten, die keine Muttersprachler sind, wie das denn auf Englisch wohl heißen würde. Und dann fragt man so einen Engländer und der sagt dann, das gibt es bei uns gar nicht oder so. Das ist ganz witzig. Grundsätzlich habe ich mich mal vor einiger Zeit mit einem der Engländer der ersten Stunde unterhalten, der hat sich da relativ verwundert darüber geäußert und sagte, also sie hätten eigentlich gedacht, dass in jedem Land durchaus auch Sprachtext in der jeweiligen Landessprache benutzt werden. Auch für so etablierte Sachen, also auch zum Beispiel für Straßen und so. Und dass man dann halt in irgendeiner Weise dann Umsetzung machen muss, dass man halt sagt, gut, der Kartenrenderer, der hat halt da so zwei, drei verschiedene Regelsätze ein für das deutsche Netz und einen fürs englische Netz und muss halt unterschiedliche Sachen auswerten. Das hatten die sich am Anfang grob so überlegt, dass das so sein könnte, aber hat sich halt nicht so ergeben. Das haben dann doch alle irgendwie besser gefunden, mit den englischen Ausdrücken umzugehen. Wer weiß, ob sich das ändern wird, wenn erstmal die Chinesen in großer Menge dazukommen oder so. Grundsätzlich sind die Keys and Values alle UTF-8. Das heißt, die Chinesen haben auch eine Chance.
Vielleicht noch mal als Letztes zu dieser Qualität. Du hast ja vorhin auch schon gesagt, dieser Vorwurf, wenn man damit aber ordentlich Autos durchgegangen navigieren will, geht das ja nicht. Wie untauglich ist denn das Straßenmaterial für eine solche Anwendung, wie automatisch geführte Straßenavigation, was jetzt so ein Tom-Tom-Gerät macht? Was muss sozusagen dafür erfasst werden? Also nochmal dieses Beispiel, ich ziehe jetzt los und erfasse meine Straße. Du hast ja gesagt, okay, Mittellinie kann ich nachvollziehen. Im Idealfall oder Minimalfall könnte man eine Straße einfach als eine dünne Linie darstellen. Wenn man ganz abstrakt rendert, dann ist da halt einfach so eine dünne Linie. Man sieht jetzt dieser Straße nicht an, wie groß die ist oder wie wichtig die ist oder vor allem wie breit sie ist. Aber ich kann eben noch weitere Sachen hinzufügen. Aber was ist quasi dann auch wirklich für so eine Navigation eine entscheidende Information, wo die Datenbank oder irgendeine Software, die da drüber schaut, auch sagt, naja, da bestehe ich aber jetzt darauf, dass diese Information auch wirklich vorhanden ist? Ist das irgendeine Abstraktionsebene, wie ich muss jetzt wissen, hier ist eine Spur, ich muss jetzt wissen, hier ist eine Fahrtrichtung, ich weiß nicht genug über die Verkehrsregeln. Also gibt es da irgendeinen Modellenüberbau, irgendein Subsystem, was sicherstellt oder zumindest erfragt, was da gefordert ist oder einem hilft?
Auch da muss man wieder sehen, das ist eben nicht ein Projekt, wo jemand von vornherein irgendwie einen großen Katalog macht und sagt, so muss es aber sein, sondern jeder, der versuchen will, auf OpenStreetMap Daten zu navigieren, der muss einfach erstmal das nehmen, was da ist. Und das, was da ist, das fängt damit an, da ist überhaupt eine Straße. Die Straße ist an einer bestimmten Stelle mit einer anderen Straße verbunden. Es ist nicht etwa so, dass die kurz davor endet, sondern da ist wirklich eine Verbindung. Solche Informationen müssen natürlich da sein, man braucht ein Netz von Straßen.
Und so eine Verbindung ist, ich meine, wie entnehme ich diese Information, dass die Straßen wirklich miteinander verbunden sind? Muss ich gucken, ob da ein Zaunobjekt steht oder muss ich eine Information, hier sind die auch verbunden hinzufügen?
Die Information, dass sie verbunden sind, kommt daher, dass wir eben diese Node- und Way-Objekte haben. Und wenn zwei Ways sich an ein Node teilen, dann sind sie an dieser Stelle verbunden.
Okay, alles klar.
Also das ist mal die grundlegende Information, die man braucht, um Navigation machen zu können. Das ist auch was, was immer mal wieder Probleme macht, wenn ein Anfänger, denen es nicht so richtig klar ist, und die zeichnen halt mehrere Punkte übereinander ein und wissen nicht, dass da keine echte Verbindung besteht. Wenn man das aber hat, dann hat man ein Straßennetz, auf dem man im Prinzip schon mal sagen kann, ich bin hier und ich will da hin, und dann kann man da eine Route finden. Um das natürlich wirklich benutzbar zu machen, brauchen wir weitere Informationen. Als Erstes sind da sicher Einbahnstraßen zu nennen. Wenn ich eine Straße nur in einer Richtung fahren kann, dann sollte der mich nicht in die andere Richtung durchrouten. Dann natürlich der Straßentyp ist ganz wichtig. Auf einer Bundesstraße kann ich typischerweise schneller fahren als auf einer Wohnstraße. Diese Sachen kann ich im Straßentyp schon mal entnehmen. Und damit allein mit diesen Informationen kann man durchaus schon ein Routing machen, was so schlecht gar nicht funktioniert. Wenn man mehr haben will, dann kommen da natürlich Sachen dazu, wie Geschwindigkeitsbeschränkungen, solche Sachen. Was schön wäre, sind Informationen, welche Spuren ich habe und so was. Das ist aber eine Sache, die bei OpenStreetMap noch überhaupt nicht erfasst wird. Es gibt da Experimente, aber es findet nicht wirklich statt, dass man, heute ist man gewohnt bei der Autonavigation, dass das Gerät einem sagt, jetzt bitte rechts einordnen und in 50 Metern dann rechts abbiegen, solche Sachen. So weit sind wir noch nicht, dass wir das machen können. Was man braucht, Informationen auch, sind Abbiegebeschränkungen. Darf ich an dieser Stelle links abbiegen? Wenn da eine Kreuzung ist, heißt das dann noch lange nicht, dass ich da auch wirklich links abbiegen darf. Solche Informationen, das war inzwischen lange Zeit unklar. Inzwischen ist es klar, wie solche Sachen zu erfassen sind. Und das fängt jetzt an, dass das gemacht wird. Also es gibt da sozusagen so eine Hierarchie von Daten. Umso mehr man hat, umso besser wird das Routing-Ergebnis. Aber man kann auch mit den einfachen Daten, kann man schon was erreichen. Die Frage ist natürlich immer, was man haben möchte. Wenn ich irgendwo auf der Webseite sitze und sage, ich möchte ja von Karlsruhe nach Berlin fahren, habe ich andere Anforderungen, als wenn ich im Auto sitze und jetzt hier im Kleinen räume ich die Navigation. Ich suche jetzt diesen einen Ort und in einer komplexen Innenstadt-Situation, wo es viele Einbahnstraßen gibt.
Also in so einer Situation, dass wir gesagt haben, ich will hier von Karlsruhe nach Berlin fahren, dass wir da eine Route rauskriegen, die in der berechneten Zeit ungefähr dem entspricht, was auch andere Routen-Plane einem ausgeben. So weit waren wir schon vor einem Jahr. Das ist aber auch eine relativ einfache Anforderung, denn da muss man halt nur, da reicht es, wenn die Autobahnen und die großen Straßen drin sind und so. Weil nur die für diese Distanzen eine Rolle spielen. Und wenn man jetzt halt sagt, ich bin kleinräumig, am schlimmsten Fall noch, ich will zu deren der Adresse, dann müssen auch die Adressen erfasst sein. Auch das ist etwas, wo wir erst langsam mit anfangen bei OpenStreetMap. Dann ist das ein bisschen eine größere Herausforderung. Auch gerade eben ganzen Einbahnstraßen, Wohnstraßen und die Abbiegerestriktionen und so. Aber es gibt trotzdem sehr viele Leute, die sagen, das kann doch nie funktionieren. Das ist doch alles ein Murks. Ihr habt die und die und die Schwächen in eurer Modellierung drin und so. Und auf der anderen Seite stehen halt funktionierende Web-Services, wo man drauf gehen kann, sich eine Route brechen lassen kann. Und man sieht also, klar, es mag ein, zwei konstruierte Fälle geben, wo ich es nicht finde, aber in den allermeisten Fällen funktioniert es. Und wenn man mal ganz ehrlich ist, wenn ich jetzt mal ein gekauftes Navi nehme, da gibt es auch Fälle, in denen das nicht funktioniert. Und da muss sich OpenStreetMap, glaube ich, jetzt nicht verstecken.
Ich habe mich mal ein bisschen mit, also ich habe mir vor kurzem auch darüber schlau gemacht, was TomTom zum Beispiel alles so macht. Da kommen wir jetzt auch noch mal ein bisschen in diese Zeit- und Metadatengeschichte. Also um wirklich jetzt auch nochmal kurz bei der Navigation auch zu bleiben. Also um dieses Routing optimal zu machen, ist ja mehr als nur, wie schnell darf man fahren, sondern es wird ja mittlerweile auch erfasst, wie schnell wird auch gefahren. Weiß nicht, ob euch das bekannt ist, also die arbeiten da ja mit Vodafone zusammen und die anonymisieren ja tatsächlich dann so die sich auf den Straßen bewegenden Mobiltelefone und solche Sachen, das ist alles ganz abgefahren. Auch das ist auch so etwas vorstellbar, dass man solche dynamischen, sich vor allem über die Zeit auch ändernden Informationen machen oder ist derzeit die OSM-Datenbank eigentlich eher dafür ausgelegt, den Ein-Ist-Zustand heute zu beschreiben?
Also ich denke, Letzteres ist richtig, OpenStreetMap hat im Moment unzureichende Maßnahmen, um sich mit solchen Dingen, also wenn jetzt aus irgendwelchen Tracks die Information gewonnen werden kann, dass grundsätzlich freitags zwischen 15 und 18 Uhr es sehr schwierig ist, sich auf dieser Straße vorzubewegen oder so. Solche Informationen hätten durchaus, also wenn sie verallgemeinert sind, hätten durchaus...
Also in Hamburg gibt es zum Beispiel diese berühmte Straße da an der Binnenalster, die halt an einem Wochentag, also nicht am Wochentag, wie war das? Vormittags in die eine Richtung, nachmittags in die andere Richtung geht es, so eine Sache.
Solche Sachen können wir und können wir erfassen und erfassen wir auch. Aber so Sachen wie jetzt gerade ist hier ein Stau oder jetzt gerade ist hier offenbar ein Unfall passiert, denn die Fahrzeuge bewegen sich alle langsam, so weit sind wir noch nicht. Und wenn das ist auch nicht ganz sicher, ob sich sowas bei OpenStreetMap etabliert oder dann eher in einer, sag ich mal, in einer Partnerdatenbank, die für solche volatilen Informationen dann da ist. Da gibt es Leute, die spielen damit rum, auch mit so Navigationssystemen auf OpenStreetMap-Basis, die sich dann untereinander verständigen, die also dann in so einer Art, also die gar nicht mehr mit einem zentralen Server reden, sondern irgendwie so mit einem Nachbargerät, das sie erreichen können und sowas. Ganz, ganz interessante. Aber das ist alles noch so Pre-All-Fahrzeug.
Aber wenn man jetzt sozusagen gesicherte Erkenntnisse darüber hat, wann eine, also ich frage mich jetzt sozusagen noch, wie man diese Zeit da reinbringen kann. Man hat ja gesagt, ok, so Last Modification, so eine Sachen, das ist alles drin. Google Earth ist ja vor kurzem aktualisiert worden. Werde dir vielleicht mitbekommen haben, wo jetzt auch so dieses schöne, wenn die Zeit sozusagen vorhanden ist, dann hat man jetzt sozusagen noch so einen Zeithebel und kann dann so in die Vergangenheit marschieren, was natürlich auch sehr interessant ist, quasi nochmal so eine Zeitachse mitten in die Daten reinzukriegen. Wäre auch das mit den Tags realisierbar?
Also theoretisch ist das natürlich möglich. Also man kann das mit diesen Tags machen. Das Problem ist, dass wir im Moment, also alle Daten landen hier an einer Datenbank. Und jedes Mal, wenn man mit den Daten arbeitet, dann holt man sich erst mal diese gesamten Informationen und muss damit irgendwie zurechtkommen. Wenn ich jetzt noch die 17 Stände, wie es früher war, alle immer sehen müsste, dann könnte man wahrscheinlich mit den Tools, die wir heute haben, nicht mehr vernünftig auf den Daten arbeiten. Dann habe ich da eingetragen, jetzt die alte Römerstraße oder irgendetwas, die quer durch meine Stadt geht. Und wenn es den Leuten nicht klar ist, was das bedeutet, dann wäre das sehr verwirrend.
Also die Vergangenheit ist bei OpenStreetMap noch Zukunftsmusik.
Genau, so kann man das sagen.
Gut, dann will ich euch mit meinem Gedanken-Spiel nicht weiter quälen, sondern wir sollten noch mal ein bisschen mehr an die möglichen Anwendungen ankommen. Bevor wir das machen, muss ich aber noch mal hinterfragen, was ist denn jetzt sozusagen die Ist-Infrastruktur? Vorhin haben wir so auf den Blick, wie hat alles angefangen, geguckt. Was gibt es konkret an Infrastruktur, die jetzt dieses OpenStreetMap-Projekt ausmachen? Was gibt es?
Also wir haben eine dicke, zentrale MySQL-Datenbank, die läuft in London. Und das ist das Herz von dem Projekt. Da läuft diese Datenbank und alle Schreibzugriffe müssen über diese Datenbank laufen. Davor hängt eine in Rails geschriebene API. Das heißt, niemand darf direkt irgendwelche SQL-Befehle da hinschicken, sondern es geht über irgendwelche Restrequests an diese API. Also alle Editoren, die man einsetzt und auch Datenhochlader und so, die sprechen alle mit dieser API. Und Daten runterladen kannst du entweder auch direkt von dieser API, wenn es sich um einzelne Objekte handelt oder um einen kleinen Bereich. Wenn du größere Mengen von Daten runterladen willst, dann wirst du in der Regel dich entweder an ein Read-Only-Mirror wenden. Das heißt, es gibt so ein paar Leute, die halt, oder ich muss anders sagen, auf dem API-Server werden regelmäßig Dumps gemacht. Einmal in der Woche gibt es einen kompletten Dump, das nennen wir den Planet Dump. Das ist alles drin, das ist der gesamte Ist-Zustand ohne Historie. Die Größenordnung ist also ein XML-File, das 120 GB groß ist, komprimiert dann bzip2, 5 GB oder so etwas.
Also ähnlich, wie auf Wikipedia das macht.
So ähnlich, ja. Und dazu gibt es dann tägliche Diffs und es gibt auch stündliche und mittlerweile sogar minütliche Diffs zu diesem Planet-File, sodass du in der Lage bist, wenn du das möchtest, dir einen eigenen Mirror aufzusetzen, den du immer fortschreibst, der dann zwar einige Minuten hinter dem Master hinterherhinkt, aber nicht viel. Und es gibt ein paar Leute, die auf dieser Technologie Read-Only-Mirrors aufgesetzt haben, die dann auch in der Lage sind, zum Beispiel größere Requests, wo du sagen kannst, gib mir die Daten von einem ganzen deutschen Bundesland oder sowas, wo die API dann schon einknicken würde und sagen würde, nee, du, das kriegst du von mir nicht, denn ich muss mich auch noch mit anderen Sachen beschäftigen. Oder was es dann eben gibt, ist Leute, das machen wir zum Beispiel auch, dass wir dieses Planet-File halt täglich verhackstücken in Ausschnitte für einzelne Länder oder auch in Deutschland für einzelne Bundesländer und die dann zum Download anbieten. Also je nachdem, was dein Anwendungszweck ist, holst du dir die Daten auf einem dieser Wege. Und dann ist natürlich eine ganz, ganz wichtige Komponente neben dem, was diesem ganzen Bereich dann mit den Rohdaten zu tun hat, Karten. Obwohl eigentlich, wie viele im Projekt sagen immer, die Herstellung von Karten ist eigentlich gar nicht der Kern von unserem Projekt. Wir sind ein Datensammelprojekt. Wir wollen diese Daten erheben und in der Datenbank katalogisieren und so weiter und so weiter. Karten, das können auch andere machen. Aber natürlich ist es ganz wichtig, dass OpenStreetMap eine Karte anbietet, damit einfach überhaupt jeder sehen kann, was wir tun. Die Karte ist einfach das Mittel der Kommunikation mit dem, insbesondere dem Outsider, aber auch mit Leuten, die selber mappen und die einfach eine Erfolgskontrolle haben wollen. Und da gibt es zwei technologisch leicht unterschiedlich aufgesetzte Systeme. Einmal die sogenannte MAPNIC-Karte, die wird von einem zentralen Renderer erzeugt. Oder die sogenannte tiles-at-home-Karte, die wird in einem, ja so, tiles-at-home, das ist so eine Anlehnung an seti-at-home und sowas, die wird verteilt gerechnet und die fertigen Kartenkacheln werden dann hochgeladen an die Zentrale. Beide Kartenansichten haben aber gemein, dass da letztlich praktisch ein großer fetter Webserver ist, der diese Kartenkacheln rausliefert, genauso wie bei Google auch. So 256 auf 256 Pixel PNGs, die dann im Browser von diesem OpenLayers, also von so einer JavaScript-Bibliothek zu einer Kartenansicht zusammengesetzt werden. Das sind die Key-Elemente der Infrastruktur, die Datenbank mit den Dumps und den Read-Only-Mirrors und die Kartenerstellungsinfrastruktur.
Und das Ganze ruht dann unter OpenStreetMap.info?
Org.
Org, ja. Aber es gibt auch Info.
OpenStreetMap.info, das ist die Domain, die wir haben für unser Buch. Das ist die Begleitseite zum OpenStreetMap-Buch. openstreetmap.org ist die Original-Projektseite in England.
Euer Buch, das habe ich ja noch komplett verschwiegen. Jetzt, wo wir was gesagt haben, erwähnen wir es vielleicht noch mal kurz. Ihr seid sehr aktiv in der Szene, das merkt man ja auch. Ihr habt ein Buch bereits veröffentlicht in einer ersten Auflage. Eine zweite ist unterwegs. OpenStreetMap heißt es. Was kann man dazu noch sagen?
Ja, genau. Die erste Auflage kam raus letztes Jahr. Und jetzt die zweite Auflage, die wir jetzt gerade dabei sind, wird Mitte März voraussichtlich erscheinen. Da haben wir also noch mal so ein bisschen die ganzen Sachen, die sich im letzten Jahr getan haben. Der Agents ist auch ein bisschen dicker geworden jetzt.
Es gibt weltweit kein besseres Buch als dieses über OpenStreetMap. Nicht, weil dieses so gut wäre, sondern weil es das einzige ist.
Das Buch beschreibt einerseits, wenn man selber Daten beitragen will, wie man das macht, wie das funktioniert, wie man mit dem GPS-Gerät umgeht, wie man die Software bedient usw. Und andererseits auch, wenn man die Daten nutzen will, wie man das machen kann, wie die Kartenrenderer funktionieren, wie man sich selber eine Karte machen kann und wie die ganzen Datenformate funktionieren usw. Es ist also quasi so ein Querbeet-Übersicht über das ganze Projekt, was sowohl den Mappern auf der einen Seite als auch den Kartennutzern erklären soll, wie man damit umgehen kann.
Okay, und ist auf Deutsch?
Ist auf Deutsch, ja.
Gut, aber das eigentliche Projekt und die Karten, über die wir jetzt die ganze Zeit gesprochen haben, natürlich unter openstreetmap.org.
Genau, was man vielleicht noch kurz zur Infrastruktur sagen kann. Es gibt natürlich auch, wie bei Open-Source-Projekten und so weiter, übliche, es gibt ein Wiki und es gibt Mailinglisten und es gibt ein Subversion-Repository für die Software. Und es gibt so die üblichen Dinge, ein Irg-Channel und was weiß ich alles, um die, was die Community eben braucht, um sich zu organisieren. Insbesondere das Wiki ist natürlich wichtig, weil da auch die Dokumentation stattfindet, weil da drin steht, wenn man sich dann nun mal geeinigt hat, oder vielleicht auch, wenn man sich nicht geeinigt hat, wie verschiedene Leute, verschiedene Sachen taggen. Solche Informationen stehen da drin. Termine für irgendwelche Mapping-Parties oder so. Wir haben doch überhaupt nicht über Mapping-Parties geredet, genau. Das fällt mir gerade ein. Mapping-Parties ist, wenn man sich trifft, typischerweise an einem Wochenende eine Gruppe von Leuten und mal sagt, okay, wir gehen jetzt systematisch, mehr oder weniger systematisch, mal irgendeine Gegenansage. Wir nehmen uns jetzt mal hier diese Stadt vor. Und dann trifft man sich, macht ein bisschen aus. Okay, du gehst dahin, du gehst dahin. Und verteilt sich die Arbeit so ein bisschen. Zieht los, trifft sich dann wieder, setzt sich irgendwo um den Tisch mit den Laptops, gibt die Daten ein und hinterher geht man Bier trinken. Sowas nennt sich Mapping-Party.
Und das ist, was den Programmierern ihr Coding-Sprint ist, sozusagen hier das gemeinsame Wandern. Genau. Mit GPS-Tracker in der Hand. Und dann laufen alle los. Und weil man irgendwie in so einem großen Rudel ist, werden auch Metadaten erfasst, an die man sonst nicht gedacht hätte, weil fünf kümmern sich schon um die Straßenbegrenzung und der Rest zählt dann nur die...
Ja, man läuft normalerweise nicht im Rudel los, sondern das eigentliche Mapping macht man dann schon alleine oder vielleicht mit ein, zwei Leuten zusammen, damit man auch mehr Gegend einfach abdecken kann. Und man läuft dann halt einen halben Tag los und trifft sich wieder und dann teilt man sich wieder auf, sodass man... Das eigentliche Datensammeln bringt eigentlich nichts, wenn man da zu sehr vielen zusammen ist. Kann man natürlich machen, gerade wenn man vielleicht einen Anfänger dabei hat. Das ist ideal, den kann man so ein bisschen einführen, kann den zeigen, wie das funktioniert.
Und diese Mapping-Partys, die werden auch teilweise über openstreetmap.org dann vermittelt?
Die sind auf openstreetmap.org, gibt es so einen Kalender, wo alle Events, die weltweit stattfinden, eingetragen werden können. Und da stehen also die Sachen immer wieder drin, ist direkt auf der Homepage. Und wird natürlich auch gelegentlich in Mailinglisten announced und so weiter. Es gibt eine weltweite Mailingliste und es gibt für viele Länder auch schon lokale Mailinglisten. Inzwischen in Deutschland gibt es also sicher mehr als ein Dutzend lokale Mailinglisten auch für einzelne Städte schon oder einzelne Regionen, wo man sich organisieren kann. Da gibt es auch auf openstreetmap.de, also auf der deutschen Projektseite, gibt es da auch Informationen zu. Da kann man also auch sehen, welche lokalen Gruppen es gibt. Und vielleicht wird es demnächst auch mal häufiger die aktuellen News geben. Das ist immer so ein bisschen schwierig, da muss ich jemandem kümmern.
Gut, aber bevor man sich jetzt ein Ausflugsziel wählt, muss man natürlich auch erstmal wissen, wo lohnt es sich am meisten. Da stellt sich für mir erstmal die Frage, was ist eigentlich drin? Also was? Das Projekt ist jetzt fünf Jahre alt. Ich habe neulich so ein Video gesehen, das werdet ihr sicherlich kennen, das ist irgendwie so durch die Listen gegangen, wo jemand mal die Änderungen und die Hinzufügungen zu der gesamten Datenbank visualisiert hat. Das kann ich jetzt aus dem Kopf nicht nachvollziehen mehr, was das alles betroffen hat. Also was ist bereits abgedeckt von der Welt und vor allem was für Informationen sind eigentlich so im Wesentlichen drin?
Also geografisch abgedeckt, das Projekt hat in Europa gestartet, deswegen hat Europa dann einen Fortschritt und es ist auch natürlich die Länder, wo Leute viel Geld haben, sich GBS-Geräte zu kaufen und so weiter.
Klar, wo es auch erlaubt ist.
Und wo es auch erlaubt ist. Das heißt grundsätzlich ist die Abdeckung in Europa tendenziell so ein bisschen besser als sonst auf der Welt. In Deutschland insbesondere ist die Abdeckung sehr, sehr gut. Deutschland ist auch mit Abstand die größte Community weltweit gesehen. Dann gibt es andere Länder wie zum Beispiel die Niederlande, die sehr gut abgedeckt ist. Niederlande, da sind Daten von einer Firma importiert worden. Die hat Daten gespendet. Und die sind importiert worden quasi als Grundstock. Und werden jetzt von der Community weiter gepflegt. Auch andere Länder, also England natürlich auch als Gründungsort, ist relativ gut abgedeckt. Die skandinavischen Ländern sind zum Beispiel viel. Und es ist aber auch sehr lokal unterschiedlich. Es ist häufig so, dass es so Hotspots gibt. Es gibt irgendwelche Gegenden, wo viele Leute sind und andere, wo es noch ein bisschen leerer aussieht. Das entwickelt sich aber sehr, sehr schnell. Und wenn man da heute sagt, da hinten, da ist es ja noch ganz dünn, dann guckt man morgen hin und plötzlich war da jemand aktiv. Es ist dann doch erstaunlich, wie schnell das gehen kann, wenn da ein paar Leute sowas in die Hand nehmen. In den USA sind auch Daten importiert worden, die sogenannten Tiger-Daten, die das Census Bureau da zur Verfügung stellt, also der Volkszählungsbehörde. Straßendaten sind hauptsächlich importiert worden und werden jetzt da von der Community weiter gepflegt. Und es gibt noch einige andere Gegenden, wo Sachen importiert worden sind. In Dänemark sind z.B. kürzlich, so wie es aussieht, die ganzen Hausnummern von jedem einzelnen Haus in Dänemark importiert worden. In Entwicklungsländern, die sind stark am Aufholen. Es gibt also durchaus einige Orte irgendwo im tiefsten Afrika, wo man nicht erwartet hätte, dass es da irgendwas gibt. Aber die Karten sehen tausendmal besser aus, als was irgendjemand sonst auf der Welt da zu bieten hat, weil da natürlich relativ wenig kommerzielles Interesse dahinter steckt. In Afrika irgendeine Karte zu machen, während ein Hobbyist dem ist es sehr egal, ob er das Ding nahe verkaufen kann.
Also es sind eigentlich wirklich noch so pre-kolumbianische Zeiten und man hat so ganz viele weiße Flecken noch auf der Weltkarte, wo so draufsteht, hier wie Dragons. Und wer sozusagen das Abenteuer sucht und eine lustige Geoparty feiern möchte, der kann sich vor allem dann auch diese ganzen unerfassten Bereiche machen. Aber da geht es jetzt erstmal, du hast gesagt, geografische Daten. Also das ist sozusagen erstmal dieses Straßen, aber eben auch Gelände.
Also das ist erstmal die, also geografisch die ganze Welt eben gesehen, was, in welchen Bereichen gibt es viel und in welchen gibt es wenig. Die Frage, was denn da genau erfasst wurde, ist eben die nächste Sache. Und da fängt es natürlich ganz klar an mit dem Straßennetz, dass es immer irgendwo Straßen und Wege, damit muss man ja irgendwo anfangen, wenn ich keinen Weg habe, den ich langfahren kann. Dazu kommen dann weitere Sachen, Eisenbahnlinien, Straßenbahnlinien, solche Sachen natürlich. Dann natürliche Gegebenheiten, Flüsse, Wälder oder auch sonstige Landschafts, wo irgendwelche Felder sind oder solche Sachen werden als erfasst. Wälder gibt es, gibt es sehr viele oder größere Seen oder sowas. Das kann man gut auch von Satellitenbildern erfassen. Es ist nicht so, dass alle Leute wirklich immer mit GPS-Geräten umlaufen müssen, sondern teilweise kann auch von Satellitenbildern gearbeitet werden. Da können wir vielleicht nachher nochmal drauf kommen. Das heißt, solche größeren Flächenobjekte und viele POIs, also Points of Interest, wo Restaurants sind, Bäckereien, Briefkästen, Behörden, Schwimmbäder, was weiß ich. Also diese ganzen Informationen werden natürlich auch erfasst. Es ist sehr verschieden. In manchen Ländern oder manchen Gegenden sind die Leute nur an Straßen interessiert. In anderen zeichnen sie alle Gebäude ein. Also es gibt da durchaus ganz erhebliche Unterschiede, was denn genau erfasst wird. Das ist auch am besten, wenn man das wissen will, guckt man sich einfach mal die Karte an und zoomt da ein bisschen rein und raus und guckt da ein bisschen, was da ist. Hängt eben davon ab, was die Leute interessiert, aber auch was an Möglichkeiten da ist. Wir haben zum Beispiel von Berlin sehr gute Satellitenbilder, was dazu geführt hat, dass in Berlin Massivgebäude erfasst worden sind. Berlin war eine der ersten Städte, wo das auf der Welt überhaupt gemacht worden ist.
Was heißt ihr Hab, Satellitenbilder?
Da müssen wir vielleicht ein kleines bisschen weiter ausholen. Satellitenbilder abzeichnen. Es gibt zwei wesentliche Quellen da im Projekt, wo wir Satellitenbilder oder ich sag mal Luftbilder allgemein herbekommen können. Eine sind die Landsatbilder von der NASA. NASA ist da schon eine Weile her, hat die vom Satelliten die ganze Erde abfotografiert und diese Informationen stehen frei zur Verfügung. Diese Daten kann man von der NASA runterladen.
Und sind die dann auch in der OSM-Datenbank? Nein, die Bilder sind... Also ist die OSM-Datenbank auch für Fotos gedacht?
Nein, die Bilder sind nicht in der OpenStreetMap-Datenbank. Aber da wir sie frei verwenden und abzeichnen dürfen, ist es eingebaut in den Editoren, dass man sich die Bilder im Hintergrund quasi anzeigen lassen kann und dann abmalen. Verstehe. Und das ist... Also Landsat ist diese eine Quelle. Und die andere Quelle, wichtige Quelle, ist Yahoo. Yahoo hat nämlich erklärt, dass es in Ordnung ist, dass wir ihre Satellitenbilder, die sie haben, dass wir die abzeichnen dürfen.
Aber die haben die doch auch gekauft?
Die haben die auch irgendwoher gekauft. Aber teilweise wohl auch einfach die Landsatbilder genommen und dann hier und dort genauere und bessere Bilder gekauft. Das ist das Problem an den Landsatbildern. Die sind nicht besonders genau. Das reicht also, um irgendwie Wälder und große Seen und so etwas abzuzeigen, aber einzelne Gebäude.
Die sind nicht sehr detailreich oder nicht sehr hochauflösend, aber die sind schon genau im Sinne von, die sind schon an der richtigen Stelle.
An der richtigen Stelle sind sie normalerweise schon. Ab und zu gibt es mal Probleme, aber das ist nicht so schlimm. Aber man kann jetzt einzelne Gebäude oder sowas nicht erkennen. Und Yahoo! hat die Bilder lizenziert irgendwo her und unter irgendwelchen Bedingungen und so weiter. Im Detail wissen wir das auch nicht, aber es gibt da eine offizielle Aussage von denen, dass das vereinbar ist mit ihren Bedingungen, die sie da haben und die sie eben offensichtlich auch von dem Upstream haben, dass OpenStreetMap diese Bilder abzeichnen darf. Das heißt, wir haben kein Copyright, kein Recht an den Bildern selber, aber wir dürfen sie benutzen als Basis, um eigene Daten davon abzuleiten und dann unter die CCPSA zu stellen. Und deswegen ist auch das in den Editors natürlich eingebaut, dass man auf die Bilder zugreifen kann. Und in Berlin zum Beispiel gibt es sehr gute, sehr hochauflösende Bilder, wo man jedes einzelne Gebäude sehen kann. Und da sind viele Gebäude erfasst. Und wenn man sich den Berliner Zoo anguckt, dann sieht man, dass da auch das Elefantenhaus irgendwie mit drin ist. Und solche Details, also wenn die Daten zur Verfügung stehen, dann kann man eine ganze Menge machen. Wir haben jetzt auch gerade noch ein anderes Projekt am Laufen. Das ist eine begrenzte Kooperation mit dem Bayerischen Landesvermessungsamt. Die haben uns Luftbilder mit ungefähr 3,5 Meter Bodenauflösung zur Verfügung gestellt. Nur für ein begrenztes Testprojekt, das bis Ende März laufen wird. Und nur für den Bereich der Oberpfalz. Und haben gesagt, ihr dürft die abmalen. Wir haben das bei uns in den Editoren eingebaut, dass man die im Editor sehen kann. Und haben allen Meppern gesagt, hier könnt ihr loslegen. Und da kann man auch deutlich sehen, dass das funktioniert. Also da sind eine ganze Menge Leute drauf angesprungen. Und haben eine ganze Menge Straßen eingetragen, was man eben auf den Bildern sehen kann. Für Gebäude reicht die Auflösung typischerweise nicht, außer große Fabrikhallen oder sowas. Aber gerade so die ganzen Waldwege oder sowas, was sehr lange dauern würde, bis man die alle abgefahren ist, da ist man mit dem Satellitenbild viel schneller dran. Es fehlen natürlich Informationen wie Straßennamen oder sowas, die ergeben sich nicht aus dem Satellitenbild. Früher oder später muss man da also hin oder muss jemand haben, der die Gegebenheiten vor Ort kennt.
Wobei Waldwege, können wir mir vorstellen, ist natürlich auch schwierig, wenn da viele Bäume drumherum sind, sieht man ja von oben nicht unbedingt, wo ein Weg ist.
Ja, ist natürlich richtig. Das hängt davon ab, zu welcher Jahreszeit die jetzt genau aufgenommen wurden und so weiter. Und wie genau die Gegebenheiten sind, alles kann man nicht erfassen. Es ist ganz klar, dass man früher oder später möchte, man das auch ablaufen, sozusagen.
Ja, aber ein Waldweg ist ja auch super für eine Mapping-Party. Da ist man dann irgendwie in der frischen Luft und im Wald. Okay, habe ich verstanden. Mir ist das auch schon aufgefallen. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, habe ich das bei euch gefunden, oder ist das bei OpenStreetMap dieses Tool, wo man sozusagen das Kartenmaterial von OSM vergleichen kann mit anderen. Also erstmal unterschiedliche OSM-Karten, aber dann auch sozusagen Side-by-Side mit Google Maps.
Ja, das ist bei uns auf der Webseite, ja.
Bei euch auf der Webseite, genau. Das war ja schon sehr interessant, weil einerseits sieht man, okay, da fehlt natürlich vieles. So, auf der anderen Seite, da wo sich jetzt aber auch wirklich mal jemand drauf gestürzt hat, da sind dann wiederum auch Sachen drin, wo man, ja, wo man wahrscheinlich, also erstmal sind bestimmte Details viel genauer, so Straßenverläufe. Und natürlich dann auch, da sind aber auch Informationen drin, da können wir wahrscheinlich ewig warten, bis die bei Google Maps irgendwann mal mit reinkommen. Also eben diese Details, diese Point of Interest. Ich meine, Überwachungskameras in Google Maps kann ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht so recht vorstellen.
Grundsätzlich ist es ja so, dass die Profis, also die Teleatlas Naftek und Co., die arbeiten halt, einmal kaufen die selber auch vielleicht irgendwo Daten ein, aber ansonsten ist deren Standardmodus ist, die haben da ihre super aufgemotzten Vans, die irgendwie sechs GPS-Geräte und zwölf Kameras dran haben oder so, fahren damit durch die Gegend, zeichnen dabei alles auf, schicken die Festplatte nachher nach Indien und da wird dann alles eingeklopft, so ungefähr. Das heißt, die sind wirklich da mit dem Auto unterwegs, die könnten sich das überhaupt niemals leisten, Personalkosten-mäßig, dass sie jetzt da so einen Militär-Transporter, der hält an, da steigen da hinten zwölf Leute aus und schwärmen aus und gehen die ganzen Fußwege ab und kommen da wieder rein. Das kann ja keiner bezahlen. Da gibt es kein Business-Modell für die. Deswegen werden die das auch nicht haben. Wenn sie nicht Fußwege und Radwege irgendwo einkaufen, zukaufen können, dann werden die Großen diese Daten nicht haben, weil dahinter einfach kein ausreichendes Geschäftsmodell steckt, das die hohen Kosten rechtfertigen würde. Insbesondere gerade so was wie Fußwege und Radwege ändern sich auch viel leichter mal als eine Straße. Also der verlaufende Autobahn, wenn du den einmal erfasst hast, dann kannst du dich da praktisch darauf ausruhen. Du kannst sagen, in zehn Jahren wird die Autobahn da auch noch langlaufen. Aber irgendwie hier so der kleine Oberrheinradweg oder so was, da kann morgen schon mal irgendjemand sagen, da sind aber zu viele Leute ins Wasser gefallen, dann bauen wir mal ein bisschen anders oder so.
Das ist aber auch so eine Sache, die ich halt bemerkt habe, so wie du jetzt auch gerade sagst, diese ganzen professionellen Firmen, was machen die? Die bauen sich halt ein Auto und fahren durch die Gegend. Das ist auch alles immer so diese Perspektive, Auto. Also man nimmt eigentlich die Welt wahr, bei diesen ganzen professionellen Karten, als säße man im Auto und das ist halt auch irgendwie meistens für Leute, die im Auto sitzen. Wenn man aber jetzt viel Straßenbahn fährt zum Beispiel oder Fahrrad, steht man einfach auf dem Schlauch, nicht? Das ist einfach eine Sichtweise auf die Welt, die an der Stelle auch irgendwie nicht passt. Also allein Google Maps mal zu entlocken, wo ein Bus lang fährt. Also ich meine, gut, das ist auch leider unseren öffentlichen Nahverkehr, Unternehmen meistens nicht zu entlocken, wo ein Bus lang fährt. Im besten Fall hat man dann so ein Tramnetz oder sowas. In Berlin leide ich da irgendwie seit Jahren darunter, dass die BVG nicht in der Lage ist, mal eine Karte zu publizieren. Da müssen wir auch so ein PDF, so ein fettes, wo Straßenbahn und Buslinien mal in derselben Karte sind. Ich meine, klar, wer steigt schon vom Bus in eine Straßenbahn um? Das ist ein esoterisches Konzept. Aber irgendwie scheint die Hirnmasse da an der Stelle nicht auszureichen, was sehr schade ist. Dann habe ich mir halt irgendwie OSM angeschaut und dann so, ah ja, toll, irgendwie, Bushaltestellen. Und vor allem nicht nur so eine abstrakte, um das noch zu sagen, nicht nur so eine abstrakte, so, na ja, wir haben da so eine Bushaltestelle, die heißt, keine Ahnung, Platz, ja, die ist ungefähr da. Aber tatsächlich gibt es ja zwei. Es gibt die auf der einen Straßenseite und es gibt die auf der anderen Straßenseite. Und sie sind ja auch nicht selten sehr weit voneinander entfernt.
Wir haben schon versucht, öffentlichen Unternehmen des öffentlichen Nahverkehrs irgendwie Informationen zu entlocken über ihr Streckennetz. Oder hier, gib doch mal raus, sag doch mal. Einige sind kooperativ, da laufen auch so ein paar Sachen. Aber durchaus hört man auch oft, nee, das wollen wir nicht, weil da haben wir dann keine Kontrolle mehr drüber. Wo kommen wir dahin, da könnte ja jemand anders auch die Haltestelle plötzlich verschieben. Das ist eine Sache, die Leute oft fragen. Die sagen oft, ich habe hier irgendwelche offiziellen, amtlichen, definitiv korrekten Daten. Kann ich die bei euch einspielen und irgendwie blockieren, sodass niemand das ändern kann? Sagen wir, nee, wenn es irgendeinen Grund gibt, eure Haltestelle zu verschieben, dann macht das halt jemand. Nee, aber es gibt auch Leute, die sagen, ja, dann kann ja die Konkurrenz genau analysieren, wie mein Netz ist und wie viel Geld man braucht, um dieses Netz zu betreiben. Und kann dann eventuell dem Auftraggeber ein günstigeres Angebot machen und so. Das ist halt die Wirtschaft. Da muss man immer...
Sie gibt einem auf jeden Fall genug Anlass, den ganzen Tag mit dem Hammer auf den eigenen Kopf hauen zu wollen. Es ist wirklich schlimm. Also, das muss sich ändern. Ich denke, die Richtung wird sich ändern. Irgendwann wird man den Nahverkehrsbetrieben wahrscheinlich einfach die Daten anbieten können. Ich muss Sie nicht darum bitten, diese Daten zu liefern.
Also, die Richtung ist so ein bisschen sichtbar, dass OpenStreetMap mit dem Ansatz, wir sammeln jetzt einfach mal diese Daten alle und wir machen es halt selber. Wenn er es uns nicht gibt, dann machen wir es halt selber. Wir warten nicht mehr auf irgendjemand, dass dieser Ansatz offensichtlich funktioniert. Und jetzt andersherum immer mehr Leute kommen und zumindest mal zaghaft anfragen. Und mal sagen, wir hätten hier ja auch Daten und wie wäre das eigentlich? Und was ginge denn jetzt? Es ist sehr langsam und sehr vorsichtig, aber es gibt durchaus Bereiche, wo das funktioniert. Ganz plötzlich ist auf uns zum Beispiel das Straßenbauamt NRW zugekommen, die halt für die ganzen überregionalen Straßen in NRW zuständig sind und die gesagt haben, wir haben hier all diese Straßen und die geben wir gerne jedem, da wollen wir kein Geld für haben. Wieso auch? Das war völlig unkompliziert. Dann haben die uns eine CD geschickt und da waren diese Daten drauf. Wir haben sie online gestellt. Das war jetzt Ende letzten Jahres, zum Zeitpunkt, wo das überregionale Straßennetz in NRW schon zum großen Teil da war, sodass wir diese Daten nicht sinnvoll importieren können. Aber wir haben sie auf einer Webseite dargestellt, wo man die beiden OpenStreetMap-Daten und diese direkt vergleichen kann und sehen kann, was haben die, was haben wir, wo stimmt da was nicht überein und wo kann ich da noch was übernehmen von denen. Und umgekehrt natürlich auch, wo haben die vielleicht einen Fehler in den Daten. Weil das ist etwas, was für viele interessant sein könnte, die Daten haben, die natürlich alle immer sagen, dass ihre Daten perfekt sind, weil die sind ja perfekt und professionell erfasst. Aber wenn man mal guckt, dann sind sie es halt doch nicht. Da sind natürlich Fehler drin, weil Menschen machen Fehler und Daten veralten halt. Und für die kann OpenStreetMap eigentlich eine sehr, sehr schöne zweite Quelle sein, wo man mal vergleichen kann, was man denn eigentlich hat. Und sehen, okay, wenn es übereinstimmt, ist gut. Und wenn es nicht übereinstimmt, dann hat der ein oder andere Unrecht. Das muss man herausfinden, wer es ist.
Wie ist denn das eigentlich so mit Verkehrslinien? Also das ist auch so eine Metaebene, die durchaus vertreten ist. Also wo fährt eine U-Bahn lang? Und zwar, also ich meine, wo fährt eine U-Bahn genau lang?
Gibt es sowas? Also es gibt, Verkehrslinien werden erfasst. Also das sind natürlich zwei Sachen erstmal zu unterscheiden. Das eine ist die Trasse selbst. Das ist da, wo die Straßenbahnen oder U-Bahnlinien, also wo die Schienen liegen quasi. Das ist die eine Sache. Die andere Sache ist dann, welche Linien dann jetzt da drauf fahren. Bei U-Bahnen ist es naturgemäß schwierig, das zu erfassen mit einem GPS-Gerät. Deswegen, was vielfach da ist, sind die U-Bahn-Stationen und auch irgendwo eine Verbindung dazwischen, ob die jetzt nun genau dem entspricht, wo der Tunnel verläuft. Das würde ich nicht unbedingt immer unterschreiben wollen, dass das unbedingt überall stimmt. Aber es spielt ja eigentlich dann auch nicht so die riesengroße Rolle.
Na ja, teilweise schon. Also wenn ich jetzt eine Wohnung suche...
Und die U-Bahn direkt unter mir durchgeht.
Ja, und ich da aber ein Audiostudio reinbauen will, das ist einfach mal so Wohnung auf U-Bahn-Linie. Kannst du schon mal komplett vergessen. Also, ich habe nicht gleich eine Anwendung für.
Ja, also grundsätzlich, das ist das Schöne an Geodaten. Irgendjemand hat immer eine Anwendung für irgendwas. Es mag noch so esoterisch sein, irgendjemand wird es brauchen. Und es ist einfach was, wenn Informationen da sind und wenn es jemand interessiert, dann kann er die Sachen ja richtig erfassen.
Also wenn irgendjemand sein Tonstudio zumachen musste, weil er auf einer U-Bahn-Linie war, dann kann der ja zumindest schon mal die Linie entsprechend so verbiegen, dass sie genau da war, weiß er ja zumindest schon mal. Da kann er ja schon mithelfen.
Na ja, gut, ich meine, es gibt natürlich auch, also gerade solche Informationen, zum Beispiel jetzt in Berlin, dafür kann ich jetzt gerade sagen, da gibt es natürlich schon so Pläne, die aushängen, wo man schon sieht, wo es eigentlich lang geht.
Ja, das kriegt man raus. Das sind ja auch meist ein bisschen Entlüftungsschächte oder sonst irgendwelche Dinge, die darauf hinweisen. Das ist, habe ich jetzt mir noch nie so im Detail angeguckt, wie gut diese Daten sind. Aber das ist was, was wie alle anderen Sachen bei OpenStreetMap auch schrittweise sicher verbessert wird und was wir dann früher oder später haben werden. Was im Moment erst so ein bisschen im Aufbau begriffen ist, ist diese Frage mit Linien. Also welche Linien gehen denn da genau lang und so weiter. Das wird dann natürlich auch irre schwierig, weil das kann sich ja auch nach Tages- und Jahreszeit ändern und so weiter. Welche Linien es überhaupt gibt, Nachtbuslinien, was auch immer und so was. Da ist aber in letzter Zeit sehr, sehr viel passiert. Es gibt auch inzwischen eine Website, wo jemand mal speziell eine Karte dafür gemacht hat. www.öpnvkarte.de Die erste Domain, die ich je gesehen habe, die ein echtes Ö drin hat und nicht nur einfach mal so zum Test angelegt wurde, sondern wirklich funktioniert. Also ÖPNV-Karte mit einem echten Ö. Eine Karte, wo man komplett auf OpenStreetMap-Basis, wo man sehen kann, welche Post-Straßen-Bahnen, S-Bahn-Linien und so weiter es gibt in verschiedenen Städten. Da ist also schon eine ganze Menge da. Das ist aber sehr, sehr unterschiedlich, in welchen Städten da wieviel ist.
Aber in Berlin ist es richtig lecker, sehe ich gerade. Ja, das ist die Karte, die ich gesucht habe.
Ja, das ist ja gut, dass der Podcast dir wenigstens auch etwas gebracht hat.
Naja, davon bin ich ausgegangen. Wie ist es mit Gebäuden?
Gebäude ist auch so etwas, was sehr verschieden ist. Gebäude muss man typischerweise vom Satellitenbild abzeichnen, weil wenn man so die Mauer lang geht mit dem GPS-Gerät, das funktioniert nicht. Da sind die Daten zu ungenau, weil man die Hälfte der Satelliten nicht sieht. Die Katastroamte in Deutschland drücken diese Informationen nicht raus. In Frankreich wird da gerade darüber geredet. Es ist etwas unklar, ob das wirklich alles so klappt, aber da hat das Ministerium mal so vorläufig zumindest gesagt, dass sie bereit wären, die Katastro-Daten für ganz Frankreich rauszurücken. Sonst passiert es typischerweise so. Es gibt einige Länder wohl, wo das importiert worden ist. In den Philippinen gibt es zum Beispiel irgendeine Stadt, da haben sie von der Stadtverwaltung die Gebäude alle gekriegt. In Deutschland ist es typischerweise so, dass da wirklich jemand hin und malen setzt, diese Dinger von Hand vom Satellitenbild ab. Deswegen in Berlin sieht man da zum Beispiel sehr viel. In vielen Städten gibt es inzwischen das zumindest wichtige große Gebäude, zum Beispiel hier in Karlsruhe das Schloss und das Bundesverfassungsgericht, was vielleicht auch das Bundesverfassungsgericht dazu animiert hat, eine OpenStreetMap-Karte als Anfahrtsplan auf ihre Webseite zu setzen. Also solche wichtigen Gebäude sieht man eigentlich jetzt ganz viel. Aber es gibt halt auch inzwischen schon einige Städte, wo quasi jedes einzelne Gebäude erfasst ist.
Und wie ist das mit der Höhe? Also, wenn ich jetzt so in der Landschaft... Also, ist sowas wie eine topografische Karte derzeit machbar mit OpenStreetMap? Oder ist jetzt die Z-Achse irgendwie ein Problem?
Es gibt Leute, die machen sehr schöne topografische Karten auf Basis von OpenStreetMap-Material. Aber das sind da nur Höhenlinien auf 2D, oder wie? Da ist dann auch so Schummerungen eingezeichnet und so. Allerdings, da holen die sich immer diese Höhendaten von der NASA aus dem SRTM-Datensatz. Und nicht nativ aus OpenStreetMap.
Aber wenn ich mit so einem GPS-Trecker durch die Gegend glatsche, dann ist doch da auch eine Z-Achse mit drin.
Ja, das wird häufig so angenommen. Das zeigt tatsächlich irgendeine Höhe an, das GPS. Aber in der Praxis kann man genauso gut würfeln. Also die GPS-Höhe ist sehr, sehr ungenau. Du hast beim GPS bei der Höhenangabe durchaus mal plus-minus 100 Meter Fehler. Und nicht die X-Y-Achse plus-minus 5 Meter. Damit kann man leben. Und Z-Achse dann halt irgendwo 100 Meter daneben oder so. Es gibt jetzt diese, mehr so in dem Outdoor-Wanderer-Bereich, gibt es diese Geräte mit barometrischem Höhenmesser eingebaut. Die können, barometrischer Höhenmesser kann sehr exakt die Höhe messen. Er muss auch kalibriert sein. Das heißt, du musst entweder morgens aus dem Flugwetterbericht dir den aktuellen Luftdruck holen oder eben einem bekannten Höhenfestpunkt dein Gerät kalibrieren oder sowas.
Aber was ist denn so mit arbeitslosen Landvermessern, die nichts Wesseres zu tun haben? Die Bierflasche beiseite legen und dann irgendwie mal losstapfen und ein bisschen die Höhe messen?
Könnte man drüber nachdenken, aber da sind auch unsere ganzen Editoren und so nicht für ausgelegt. Also es ist auch so ein bisschen eine Frage, ist die Höhe jetzt konkret verbunden mit einem Objekt, das du gemapped hast, wenn jetzt irgendjemand da so einen Briefkasten einträgt? Und der Briefkasten kriegt eine geographische Länge und Breite und trägt da eine Höhe von 150 Meter über normal Null. Und jetzt stellt jemand anders fest, der Briefkasten, der ist ja falsch eingezeichnet, der gehört ja auf die andere Straßenseite. Zieht den Briefkasten rüber auf die andere Straßenseite. Was ist denn jetzt? Ist denn jetzt der Briefkasten immer noch 150 Meter hoch, obwohl er jetzt woanders ist? Oder bezog sich die gemessene Höhe, die da irgendjemand an diesen Briefkasten dran geschrieben hat, tatsächlich auf diesen Punkt auf der Erdoberfläche? Und der Briefkasten ist dadurch, dass er verschoben wurde, jetzt auch plötzlich 10 Meter tiefer oder so. Das muss alles vernünftig gelöst werden. Da müssten die Editoren auch vernünftige 3D-Darstellung haben, damit den Leuten klar ist, was sie da machen. Wir haben ja immer diese Sache bei OpenStreetMap. Wir haben es mit Leuten zu tun, die keine ausgebildeten Kartografen oder Geografen sind. Unser ganzes System muss so sein, dass jeder das bedienen kann. Dass man nicht erst eine große Ausbildung braucht, um da nichts kaputt zu machen. Das heißt, da müssen wir auch immer so ein bisschen drauf gucken. Wir haben dann durchaus die Computernerds im Projekt, die dann eben sagen, ja, da könnte man doch dies und das und dann würde alles ganz toll. Aber man muss eben immer diesen menschlichen Faktor, den muss man echt berücksichtigen und muss sich überlegen, wollen wir ein Projekt, das am Ende nur noch von Computernerds mit GPS bedienbar ist? Oder wollen wir ein Projekt, das sozusagen hinreichend stabil funktioniert, dass man auch Lieschen Müll da dran lassen kann? Und eigentlich tendenziell wollen wir eher ein Projekt, wo wir auch Lieschen Müll da dran lassen können.
Das Layer-8-Problem, ja, ja, das ist auch hier da. Bezüglich dieser Datenspenden, was wünscht ihr euch denn? Also ich meine, der eine oder andere hat sich jetzt mal so bereit erklärt, gibt es da noch? Ich meine, vielleicht hört ihr jetzt irgendjemand zu, der eigentlich auf so einem kleinen Schatz sitzt, aber es irgendwie noch nicht so richtig gerufen fühlt. Was könntet ihr euch denn so vorstellen, was man noch in diese Datenbank einfach mit reingießen kann, was eigentlich schon existiert oder vielleicht existiert oder existieren müsste? Oder vielleicht schon im Ansatz irgendwie existiert und dann müsste man nur noch mal beigehen? Gibt es da irgendwas?
Es gibt grundsätzlich so eine Klasse von Daten, die sich dem normalen OpenStreetMapper so ein bisschen schwierig erschließen, weil sie entweder sehr, sehr mühsam zu erfassen sind, wie zum Beispiel Hausnummern, um Hausnummern ordentlich zu erfassen, muss ich wirklich mehr oder weniger zu Fuß jede Straße langlaufen. Wenn ich gut bin, schaffe ich es mit dem Fahrrad, im Auto schaffe ich es dann gleich gar nicht mehr. Das ist wirklich viel Arbeit. Es gibt andere Sachen, die sind deswegen schwierig, weil sie für den Mapper gar nicht ohne Weiteres überhaupt sichtbar sind. Zum Beispiel Stadtteilgrenzen. Wir sind jetzt so weit, dass wir für ganz Deutschland ordentliche Kreisgrenzen importiert haben. Das ist schon mal viel wert. Wir wissen die Bundeslandgrenzen, wir wissen die Kreisgrenzen. Stadtgrenzen, Gemeindegrenzen, gar Stadtteilgrenzen sind noch ein ganz, ganz schwieriges Thema. Das haben wir in einigen Bereichen. Aber selbst für jemanden, der in der Stadt wohnt, ist es nicht unbedingt einfach, so eine Stadtteilgrenze mal einzuzeichnen. Und wenn, dann ist die wieder auf der Webseite von der Stadt, wo dann unten drunter steht, ja, Nutzung für privaten Gebrauch zulässig. Dann sagt man wieder, ja toll, also ich kann das da jetzt zwar abzeichnen, aber eigentlich darf ich es nicht. Da gibt es Sachen, wo es durchaus Datensätze gibt. Historische Grenzen? Historische Grenzen fallen wieder unter das, was wir vorhin gesagt haben. Die sind zwar durchaus interessant, aber wenn wir die jetzt einzeichnen, dann heißt es, dass jeder Mapper, der sich praktisch da diese Region auf den Schirm zaubert, dass er diese historische Grenze da auch sieht.
Verdiener Mauer?
Unsere Editorinnen haben halt...
Die will man ja eigentlich auch.
Unsere Editorinnen haben im Moment eben noch nicht dieses Feature, dass man sagen kann, okay, zeig mir mal nur sozusagen, lass mal die historischen Sachen alle weg. Und das ist sicherlich was, was wir in Zukunft noch angehen werden. Das wird aber auch eine große technische Herausforderung, weil es viele Objekte gibt, die dann praktisch diese Zeitachse transcendieren. Die waren damals da und sind heute immer noch da. Und es gibt andere, die waren damals da und sind heute weg. Und dann ist immer die Frage, was ist, wenn ich jetzt sozusagen... Angenommen, du zeichnest jetzt die historische Berliner Mauer und die verwendet einen Note von der Straße. Die Straße gibt es heute noch, die Mauer gibt es aber nicht mehr. Und jetzt jemand blendet den historischen View aus und korrigiert den Verlauf der Straße.
Ich habe gar nicht gefragt. Bleiben wir bei den aktuellen Sachen. Was könnte noch gespendet werden? Gibt es eigentlich, sind die GSM-Basisstationen schon drin?
Es gibt da ja mehrere Privatleute, die das sammeln, die das aber alles irgendwo in ihren Silos machen. Es gibt da eine sehr interessante Subkultur von lauter Leuten, die diese Basisstationen sammeln und durchaus auch auf Karten einzeichnen und so weiter. Aber ja, wäre schön, wenn die die einfach bei OpenStreetMap mit eintragen, dann kann man an was gemeinsam arbeiten. Also es gibt viele solche Sachen, was jetzt unter Überbegriff POI, Points of Interest fallen würde, wo es schön wäre, das einfach zu haben. Also sei es die Basisstationen, sei es alle Tankstellen, sei es, ich weiß nicht was. Also da gibt es natürlich unendlich viele Sachen. Da muss man aber auch sagen, die Leute, die da Interesse dran haben, die müssen sich darum kümmern. OpenStreetMap ist nicht, wir haben nicht die große Liste, die wir abhaken. Und wenn jemand sagt, ihm ist es wichtig, dass alle Tankstellen drin sind, dann soll er sich darum kümmern, dass sie rankommen sozusagen. Was sehr interessant wäre noch, wären Luftbilder. Luftbilder sind vielfach verwendbar, sag ich mal. Man kann da viele Informationen rausziehen. Und wir haben viele Leute, die viel Zeit haben und die bereit sind, da Informationen rauszuziehen. Klassischerweise ist das ja das Problem, ich habe da Luftbilder, aber da muss ich da Leute hinsetzen, die die Informationen da rausziehen, die Vektordaten daraus extrahieren. Das Problem haben wir so nicht, weil die Leute da sind, die die Informationen liefern können. Und wenn wir sehr gute Luftbilder hätten, könnten viel mehr Sachen gemacht werden. Und es wäre auch noch ein anderer Effekt da, wenn heute jetzt jemand käme und sagt, ich schenke euch all diese Daten. Hier, ich habe hier komplett die Katasteramtsdaten von ganz Deutschland. Das ist alles perfekt und ihr müsst gar nichts mehr machen. Daten sind nun alle da. Dann weiß ich gar nicht, ob das gut wäre für das OpenStreetMap-Projekt. Also ja, natürlich gut für die Datenbasis, aber für das Projekt als solches wäre es sehr, sehr schwierig, wie man damit umgeht. Und auch bei Luftbildern auf der anderen Seite, da sind es dann immer noch die Menschen. Da sind es die einzelnen Leute im Projekt, die entscheiden, was zeichnen sie jetzt ein und was zeichnen sie nicht ein, wie machen sie das und was ist ihnen wichtig usw. Das wäre eine sehr gute Unterstützung für die Community. Aber wir sind nicht völlig überflüssig, sozusagen.
Ähnliches Kaliber wie Luftbilder sind auch Track-Spenden. Wir haben ja heutzutage doch relativ viele, sag ich mal, Fuhrunternehmer oder Postzusteller oder so was, die standardmäßig ihre Fahrzeuge mit GPS-Geräten ausgestattet haben. Und wenn die einfach mal uns praktisch eine CD geben würden und sagen würden, hier, das ist mal hier so von einer Woche unsere Tracks, wo unsere Fahrzeuge lang gefahren sind, ein bisschen anonymisiert vielleicht oder so, dann würde uns das natürlich auch ähnlich wie ein Luftbild so ein interessantes Hintergrundmuster geben. Wir hätten dann noch null Informationen darüber, wie die Straße jetzt heißt und so, aber wir wüssten zumindest, ja gut, je nachdem, was für eine Art von Unternehmen das ist. Wenn das jetzt gerade zum Beispiel ein Kurierdienst oder eine Müllabfuhr wäre oder so was, die, ich meine jetzt im städtischen Bereich da, da nützt uns das nicht mehr viel, da sind wir jetzt gut genug. Aber gerade so im ländlichen Bereich da.
Ein Postzusteller, der mit dem Auto irgendwie...
Ein Postzusteller, der irgendwo da so an der Grenze zwischen Bayern und Tschechien mit dem Auto zu jedem einzelnen Haus fährt, der mal einfach so ein GPS in seinen Wagen legt und mal mitlaufen.
Und die Briefkastenentleerer.
Oder die, ja gut, die kommen nicht...
Man weiß, wo die Briefkasten sind.
Ja, aber die kommen irgendwie nicht zu jedem Haus hin. Also das ist ja schon, also... Die kommen zumindest nicht in Briefkassen.
Also den Track kann man das auf jeden Fall dann deutlich entnehmen, wo ein Briefkasten ist. Wo er immer so sich zwei Minuten da mal kurz aufhält. Oder ist dann... da ist er dann. Tja, das ist auch... Ich überlege auch schon die ganze Zeit, was ich so in meiner Umgebung... Weil ich bin auch erst vor zwei, drei Jahren in einen neuen Bezirk gezogen. Das ist dann immer so der Moment, wo man dann so, oh man, wo ist denn hier überhaupt was? Ja, und da hatte ich natürlich jetzt so ein bisschen den Moment so, aha, okay, alles klar, Google Maps ist da. Und hab halt wie ein Blöder da immer so das eingegeben, nicht dass ich jetzt immer eine passende Antwort erwartet habe, nur um einfach nur mal zu sehen, was kommt. Und es kam natürlich dann echt wenig. Und vor allem, und das ist auch das Interessante bei Karten, klar, Straßen und so, das kriegst du irgendwie alles bei Google Maps. Aber die Sachen, die wirklich wichtig sind, das ist genau dieser kleinen Scheiß, der vielleicht so auf den ersten Blick nicht so wichtig erscheint. So dieses, wo ist denn der Briefkasten und wann wird denn der geleert? Oder wo sind Ärzte oder wo sind sonstige Einrichtungen einer Gemeinde? Wo sind die Schulen? Wo sind Kindertagesstätten zum Beispiel? Das ist auch einfach eine Information, die ist nicht zu kriegen. Und ich hab mich dann irgendwie hingesetzt und hab dann irgendwie so die offizielle Kindertagesstätten-Liste irgendwie mit Adresse von Berlin abgetippt und dann irgendwie einzeln die Adressen in Google Maps aufgesucht und mir dann selber irgendwie meine Bookmarks gemacht. Man wird bekloppt dabei. Und das wäre halt auch sehr schön, wenn solche Sachen da hineingespendet werden würden.
Ist auch nicht umsonst, dass eine Immobilienfirma, die so Immobilien-Suche macht, dass die sehr, sehr früh dabei war bei OpenStreetMap und OpenStreetMap-Bilder in den Hintergrund legen konnte, weil das eben die entscheidenden Sachen ist. Wenn ich irgendwo hinziehen will, dann will ich wissen, nicht nur, ob da eine dicke Straße ist oder eine Wohnstraße, sondern auch wo der Kindergarten ist und so weiter.
Wie komme ich da hin? Genau, wie komme ich da weg? Das ist ganz wichtig, das stimmt. Das ist ein interessanter Punkt, wo du das sagst, hier mit Wohnungssuche. Da könnte dann auch eine Firma, die jetzt selber Wohnung anbietet, natürlich auch die OpenStreetMap-Karten einfach so verwenden und natürlich auch selber die Metadaten noch mit zu beitragen, die da gefragt sind. Ach, toll. Ja, vielleicht jetzt mal, ich meine, jetzt haben wir ja schon einiges darüber gesagt, aber das, was wir noch nicht gesagt haben, was sind denn so Anwendungen, die es bereits gibt oder die entstehen, die ihr euch vorstellen könntet für diese OpenStreetMap-Daten? Was wird heute schon daraus produziert? Was könntet ihr euch vorstellen? Was sind so Szenarien? Also Autonavigation haben wir schon durch, ist es jetzt eigentlich ja nicht so primär, aber wofür taugen die Daten jetzt schon wunderbar?
Also die Daten taugen natürlich für, erstmal als Replacement für Google-Karten oder so. Wenn einer sagt, ich möchte mich da nicht abhängig machen von einem Hersteller oder so was, oder auch für witzige Sachen, wo man Google laut Lizenzbedingungen nicht, Google-Daten darf man ja zum Beispiel eben nicht zum Tracking von Fahrzeugen oder so was einsetzen. Es gibt so eine Webseite, die heißt woistereismann.de mit Bindestrichen, so ein Bastelprojekt von der Uni in Ilmenau, glaube ich. Die haben da immer so ein mobiles Eisverkaufsfahrzeug, das da über den Campus fährt. Und dem haben sie so ein Ding gespendet, oder gekauft von irgendeiner Firma, so ein GPS-Tracker mit SMTS oder UMTS oder SMS, der seine Position hochlädt. Und da gibt es so eine Karte im Web, wo du immer siehst, wo der jetzt gerade ist.
So was.
Das ist jetzt natürlich ein Späßchen, aber so in die Richtung, da diese Geräte auch immer billiger werden, da kann man schon viele lustige Sachen machen.
Das ist super. Ich hatte zum Beispiel genau dasselbe Problem, auch mit dieser Nutzungsgeschichte. Ich habe mich irgendwann mal vor ein paar Jahren, als es diese ganze Maps-Geschichte noch nicht gab, wollte ich mich halt irgendwie partout mal beim Marathon fahren, also auf Rollschuhen jetzt, tracken, live, so because we can. Dann hatte ich auch erstmal das Problem, jetzt wollte ich das auf meiner Webseite anzeigen, wo. Also Google Maps gab es damals halt noch nicht. Es gab aber einen anderen Hersteller, der so für Berlin Karten hat, dann habe ich mir die halt so ein bisschen entlehnt. Dann haben die natürlich auch wieder gesehen, dass ich da so Zugriffe gemacht habe. Und dann gab es dann so diskrete Nachfragen. Da konnte ich mich natürlich dann irgendwie schön rausgeben, ja hier und so und alles ganz privat und so. Dann fanden sie es irgendwie auch ganz lustig. Aber es ist natürlich dann auch wieder gleich so ein rechter Fu an der Stelle.
Es gibt auch viele Sachen, die du halt nur machen kannst, wenn du wirklich die rohen Daten hast. Zum Beispiel ein ganz einfaches Beispiel. Ich meine, wir sind ja alle so in diesem Alter, dass wir noch Text-Adventures kennen. Und irgendeiner hat spaßeshalber nur so ein kleines Text-Adventure gemacht, was so eine Engine, die OpenStreetMap-Daten reinlädt. Wo du halt einfach so sagst, du stehst an der Kaiserstraße. Was willst du tun? Du sagst Nord. Und dann sagt er, du bist jetzt an der so und so Straße oder sowas. Das ist, ich glaube, das war nur mal so ein Prototyp, um eben auch so because we can. Aber das ist halt was, wenn du nur Rasterdaten bekommst oder so, kannst du sowas überhaupt technisch gar nicht machen. Es gab ein ganz interessantes Projekt, der hat auf der letzten OpenStreetMap ja so eine jährliche Konferenz, wo sich alle treffen und ein bisschen erzählen über die coolen Sachen, die sie gemacht haben. Die heißt State of the Map. Die war letztes Jahr in Limerick. Dieses Jahr wird sie in Amsterdam sein. Und diese State of the Map-Konferenz letztes Jahr, da war einer von HP da. Die hatten so ein Projekt, wo sie so Spiele, so PDA-Spiele herstellen, die einen, die Ortsbezug haben. Also er hatte eins vorgestellt, da ging es irgendwie so um den Tower in London. Du musstest da irgendwie, du hast praktisch so eine historische Episode nachgespielt. Du musstest aus dem Tower entkommen oder so. Und das Ding hatte so einen GPS eingebaut und hat dann praktisch immer, je nachdem, wo du gewesen bist, unterschiedliche Sachen angezeigt. Jetzt sind diese Spiele standardmäßig natürlich immer an einen ganz speziellen Ort gebunden. Und darauf dann eben, das hat eben nur im Tower von London funktioniert. Aber die hatten so einen Prototypen, wo du mit OpenStreetMap-Daten Location-unabhängige Spiele machen konntest. Das heißt, derjenige, der sich das Spiel ausgedacht hat, sagen wir so ein Mystery, du musst einen Kriminalfall lösen oder so was. Und da gab es verschiedene Handlungsorte in dem Spiel. Eins davon war eine Kirche, eins davon war eine Kneipe und der dritte Ort war irgendwie eine viel befahrene Straße oder was. Und der Entwickler von dem Spiel, der konnte das also so aufbauen, dass sich das automatisch parametrisiert hat nach dem Ort, wo du das Spiel startest. Also wenn du hier in Karlsruhe auf Start drückst, dann hat er sich aus den OpenStreetMap-Daten herausgesucht, wo ist hier in der Nähe eine Kirche, wo ist hier in der Nähe eine Kneipe, wo ist hier in der Nähe eine viel befahrene Straße. Und diese Orte nehme ich jetzt sozusagen als die Schlüsselorte für mein Spiel, die jetzt da irgendeine Aktion auslösen. Und dann konntest du dieses Mystery Adventure, musste sich praktisch natürlich diese Transferleistung bringen. Dass du dich jetzt sozusagen so tust, als ob du in dieser historischen Welt da wärst oder so. Und dann spielte das aber eben in Karlsruhe. Also das ist eine ganz faszinierende Sache.
Gibt denn die OpenStreetMap-API eigentlich auch so eine Fähigkeit heraus, dass ich das System frage, hier ist meine Koordinate, wo bin ich? Und dann in einer beliebigen Auflösung, dass er mir sagen kann, du bist in Karlsruhe, du bist in Deutschland. Du bist in Deutschland. Du bist in Europa oder aber auch du bist in Stadtteil, du bist in Straße.
OpenStreetMap API macht das nicht, aber es gibt von diesen Read-Only-Services, da gibt es einen, der hat so eine Funktion. Also von diesen Mirrors, die sich immer die Daten ziehen. Theoretisch ist das ja kein Problem, du musst dann nur Daten in der Datenbank schmeißen und entsprechende Request anbieten, der das rückwärts auflöst.
Aber auch sozusagen mit so einer wählbaren Auflösung.
OpenStreetMap hat jetzt nicht so ganz diese durchstrukturierte Regionseinteilung. Das heißt, dass Karlsruhe eine Stadt in Baden-Württemberg und Baden-Württemberg ein Land in Deutschland ist, das ist noch so ein bisschen, kann man nicht immer und für alle gegen in der Welt automatisiert, also OpenStreetMap ableiten. Das ist aber sicherlich was, was sich mit der Zeit entwickeln wird.
Einen müsste man mal. Und was mir auch gerade kam, wo du das sagst, so mit Spielen, kann man denn die OpenStreetMap-Infrastruktur oder zumindest die Software auch dafür verwenden, einfach eine komplett virtuelle Karte zu machen. Also angenommen, ich würde jetzt so ein Abenteuerspiel machen und ich will das aber jetzt irgendwo spielen lassen, in so meiner eigenen ausgedachten Welt. Und ich möchte jetzt auch meine Community dazu einladen, diese Welt selber zu bauen. Lassen sich dann diese ganzen Werkzeuge dafür auch herbeiziehen, so dass man da so seinen eigenen Planeten anmeldet und dann malt man halt den.
Also die Software kann man natürlich dafür verwenden, man müsste halt einen eigenen Server aufsetzen. Also die ganze Software ist so, dass sie standardmäßig eingestellt hat, dass sie auf diesen einen zentralen Server geht, den OSM bereitstellt.
Und die Software ist halt auch komplett frei.
Die Software ist komplett frei, das ist alles open source. Und das wäre jetzt kein größeres Problem, sich einen eigenen Server aufzusetzen und dann in der Software halt in der Konfig die URL von der API zu ändern und dann auf den Server zu gehen. Und dann kann man dort sowas machen. Es wäre nicht mehr OpenStreetMap, es wäre die gleiche Software, aber es wäre nicht mehr OpenStreetMap-Projekt, sondern es wäre dann irgendwo eine getrennte Geschichte.
Aber funktioniert das dann? Es funktioniert aber auch nur mit Planeten, die dann aber auch exakt genauso groß sind wie die Erde.
Ja, jein. Also die Größe spielt ja eigentlich keine Rolle. Die geografischen Koordinaten gehen von minus 180 bis plus 180 Grad und minus 90 bis plus 90 Grad. Das ist an der Größe hängst nicht. Das wäre erst dann, wenn man eine Karte mit einer Skala irgendwie anzeigen will, dann würde es wahrscheinlich schiefgehen.
Aber man könnte sich da aber auch zum Beispiel irgendwie so einen virtuellen Overlay machen, der dann auch vielleicht später wieder rückintegriert wird. Also gerade so diese Sache mit den historischen Daten. Eben damit man eben nicht mit dem aktuellen Bestand in Konflikt kommt, können wir sagen, okay, wir haben jetzt hier irgendwie den Planet Mittelalter. Wir haben jetzt hier den Planet Neuzeit und so weiter.
Das könnte man durchaus machen. Wie gesagt, die Software ist fast alles GPL oder manche Sachen sind auch einfach PD. Und das ist gar kein Problem, sich diese Sachen runterzuladen und da was zu basteln.
Aber jetzt zu den Anwendungen. Ich meine, die Anwendungen waren jetzt alle so ein bisschen mehr so Spaß und was man so privat gerne machen möchte. Wie sieht denn das so mit der wirtschaftlichen Nutzbarkeit aus? Das Projekt lädt ja auch ein, dass Firmen sich sozusagen dessen bedienen. Hatten wir ja im Prinzip schon angesprochen. Was für wirtschaftlich wirklich nutzbare Modelle lassen sich denn da so erdenken? Oder was ist da bisher gekommen? Also ich habe irgendwas im Sinn, dass irgendwo so eine Fahrradkarte sogar angeboten wird, die sich irgendwie aus OpenStreetMap-Daten...
Also es gibt diese Fahrradmaps, die CycleMap ist unter opencyclemap.org. Das ist keine kommerzielle Karte. Das hat jemand privat angefangen. Die wird allerdings jetzt unterstützt, gesponsert von CloudMade. Das ist die Firma, die Steve Coase, der Gründer vom Projekt, gegründet hat, mit anderen zusammen, die jetzt Karten kommerziell auch anbieten. Also es gibt eine ganze Menge von solchen Spezialkarten. Das ist sicher was, was interessant an OpenStreetMap ist, wenn man eben nicht die generische Karte haben will, die man bei allen möglichen Leuten bekommt, sondern irgendwas besonderes. Die Fahrradkarte oder die ÖPNV-Karte, die wir vorhin schon erwähnt haben, oder irgendwie eine Wanderkarte und es gibt jemanden, der Skipisten zum Beispiel eine Karte mit Skipisten macht. Für all diese Spezialkarten, dafür eignet sich OpenStreetMap, weil man eben die Daten einfach so erfassen kann und viele andere, die die Sachen nicht haben. Einerseits geht es um die Daten, die erfasst sind und die möglich sind, die man darstellen kann. Und dann um die Darstellung selber. Bei den normalen Kartenanbietern bekomme ich halt die 0815-Karte, so wie die das mir geben. Und OpenStreetMap ermöglicht mir, die Karten selber zu rechnen. Auch die Software, um die Karten zu erzeugen, ist open source. Da gibt es eine ganze Menge verschiedene Möglichkeiten. Das heißt, ich kann mich hinsetzen und kann sagen, ich möchte die Karte aber jetzt nicht in grün, sondern in blau. Und ich möchte dieses anders und das sollte erscheinen und das soll da nicht erscheinen. Und ich möchte bitte, dass es zu meiner Corporate Identity passt oder sowas. Das ist wohl auch eines der Sachen, was die Firma CloudMate eben machen möchte. Die verkaufen die Möglichkeit, also die haben so einen Style-Editor, dass man leicht im Web sich zusammenklicken, einen anderen Style zusammenklicken kann. Wenn man selber macht, ist es so ein bisschen Handarbeit, XML-Dateien editieren, so ein bisschen mühsam, aber kann man auch so, braucht man CloudMate nicht unbedingt für. Und dann für all die Leute, die eben ein bisschen mehr wollen als das, was die Standardkarte ist, für die ist sicher OpenStreetMap ein guter Ansatz. Im Moment ist die wirtschaftliche, also die Situation noch so, dass die gewerbliche Nutzung von OpenStreetMap noch nicht sehr weit ist, was einfach daran liegt, dass man häufig komplette Karten in irgendeiner Form braucht. Wir haben ja vorhin gesehen, es gibt eben noch diese weißen Flecken bei OpenStreetMap. Die verschwinden sehr, sehr schnell und ich denke, dass es dauert nicht mehr lange. Dann wird sich zumindest hier in Mitteleuropa der Unterschied aufgelöst haben und die Karten werden für sehr viel Zwecke verwendbar sein. Im Moment ist es aber natürlich noch so, wenn jemand sagt, ich möchte jetzt eine Deutschlandkarte haben, wo wirklich jeder Ort drauf ist und jede Straße drauf ist, dann geht es halt im Moment noch nicht. Aber für all die Sachen, wenn ich jetzt eine Autobahnkarte von Deutschland machen will, würde ich zum Beispiel sagen, es ist überhaupt kein Problem, die sind alle da. Also alles immer, wo es um Anpassungen geht oder eben Spezialdaten, da ist OpenStreetMap sicher eine gute Lösung oder wird es in Kürze sein?
Ich denke mir so Location-based Services im Wesentlichen, also so Software. Ich meine, man hat jetzt hier irgendwie, ich renne hier immer mit dem iPhone rum, irgendwie das Ding hat irgendwie GPS, das weiß halt immer, wo ich bin. Und in dem Moment ist das natürlich auch ein wunderbarer Datenquell, um Informationen zu verorten und die dann wiederum auch mobil bereitzustellen.
Es gibt mehrere Leute, die an solchen Sachen arbeiten, mehrere OpenSource-Projekte und auch Leute, die in Richtung gewerbliche Ausnutzung gehen oder OpenStreetMap-Sachen da benutzen wollen. Es gibt inzwischen einen Editor, der läuft auf dem Nokia 810 zum Beispiel, mit dem man auch unterwegs OpenStreetMap-Daten bekommen und editieren kann. Also wenn man online ist, kann man es direkt machen, und sonst muss man halt, wenn man nächste Mal WLAN-Verbindungen hat, kann man dann die Daten quasi sinken. Es gibt mehrere Möglichkeiten, auch Navigationen auf mobilen Geräten zu machen, auf Basis von OpenStreetMap-Daten. Es gibt sowohl Software, die auf dem Gerät selber läuft, zum Beispiel auf dem Nokia oder auch auf Windows-Geräten. Es gibt für die Android-Plattformen ein System, Antnav nennt sich das, das einen Webdienst benutzt. Das heißt, man muss online sein, um das Routing machen zu können. Man kann dadurch routen und die Tracks wieder sammeln. Man kann da eine Nutzungsbedingung anklicken, dass man einverstanden ist, dass seine Tracks, wenn man da rumgelaufen ist, dass die dann zu OpenStream wieder hochgeladen werden. Da beginnt sich gerade, so eine Infrastruktur und so eine Geschichte aufzubauen. Dass man auch mobile Location-Based Services machen kann. Es ist relativ schwierig, dieses ganze Kapitel, weil es so viele verschiedene Plattformen gibt und so viele verschiedene Möglichkeiten, wie man diese Software genau machen kann. Zu wenig Leute, es gibt wieder zu wenig Leute, die die einzelne Plattform haben. Deswegen dauert es ein bisschen, bis die Software rumkommt.
Wenn ich jetzt selber zu dem Projekt beitragen will, wenn ich also jetzt wirklich Daten erfassen möchte und draußen rumlaufen möchte oder auch mal konkret draußen vor Ort, was brauche ich?
Du brauchst ein GPS-Gerät typischerweise.
Was muss das so für Anforderungen erfüllen?
Das muss eigentlich nicht wahnsinnig viele Anforderungen erfüllen. Die Geräte, die man heutzutage so kaufen kann, sind alle völlig gut genug. Was es natürlich machen muss, ist, es muss die Tracks mitspeichern können, die man so abfährt. Das ist zum Beispiel ein Problem bei vielen Navigationsgeräten, die man so im Auto hat und so. Die wissen zwar, wo sie sind, aber sie geben diese Informationen nicht wieder her. Also diese Informationen braucht man natürlich. Und sie sollten auch eine Waypoint, eine Wegpunktfunktion haben. Das ist also dann, dass man einem Gerät einen Knopf drücken kann, um einen Wegpunkt zu speichern, um eine Position zu markieren, weil man diese Informationen dann wieder braucht, damit man nachher da irgendwas verorten kann. Dass man sagen kann, hier, drückt den Knopf und sagt dann, ok, das ist Punkt 17, das ist jetzt die Goethe-Straße, also eine Einbahnstraße, dass man sich diese Informationen, typisch weiß es so, dass man sich diese Informationen zusätzlich notiert. Wie gesagt, es gibt inzwischen Editoren, dass man das auch direkt machen kann. Aber der klassische Weg ist, dass man das GPS-Gerät eben nur den Track aufzeichnet plus diese Wegpunktmarkierung und man sich dann zusätzliche Notizen macht oder man macht Fotos von den Straßenschildern. Ich mache es typischerweise, wenn ich unterwegs bin mit einem MP3, einem kleinen MP3-Spieler, der eine Aufnahmefunktion hat. Man spreche mir dann Notizen drauf. Das ist also das, was man braucht, das GPS-Gerät. Alles andere am GPS-Gerät ist mehr oder weniger optional. Es ist natürlich schön, wenn man eins hat, was auch eine Karte anzeigen kann. Zum Beispiel die sehr beliebten Geräte von GAMIN, die immer wieder benutzt werden. Da gibt es inzwischen eine Softwareführer, die OpenStreetMap-Karten konvertieren kann. Das heißt, ich habe das Ding vorne auf meinem Fahrrad drauf und fahre irgendwie rum. Und ich sehe, da ist eine Straße gar nicht eingezeichnet. Dann kann ich die einfach mal langfahren und kann die Daten dann später hochladen.
Aber man kann ja sich auch schon vorstellen, dass man so mit einem Netbook, die jetzt alle irgendwie OMTS drin haben und Bluetooth, dann nimmt man sich so einen GPS-Bluetooth-Dongel, ballert sich einen Hut und dann ist man mit so einem kleinen Netbook unterwegs. Dann hat man ja auch gleich noch Internet und könnte das dann auch so direkt in die Karte eintragen.
Im Prinzip ja, aber unterschätzt nicht mal den Aufwand, den man treiben muss, um tatsächlich Daten zu erfassen. Also wenn man jetzt nicht nur einfach da langfahren möchte, sondern wenn man wirklich sagt, ich zeichne die Straße auch gleich ein und gebe ihr gleich den richtigen Namen und den Briefkasten, den klicke ich hier auch noch gleich an, da muss man schon ein hochoptimiertes Benutzerinterface haben, damit man das in der Zeit, die man sich dann eben da dran vorbei bewegt, auch machen kann. Jochen und ich haben vor einem Jahr oder so was da mal so einen Feldversuch gemacht. Ich hatte gerade den JOSM-Editor, das ist der Java-Editor, der sehr viel benutzt wird im Projekt in der Offline-Nutzung. Also wenn man halt am Abend mit seinem Track dann am Rechner sitzt und das alles reinklopft. Und ich hatte dafür einen Plugin geschrieben, dass man halt live mappen konnte, dass man eben live GPS-Positionen einlesen, sofort auf dem Schirm seine Position gesehen und konnte gleich da die Straße anlegen und so weiter. Und wir sind zu zweit im Auto gefahren, einer nur gefahren, der andere nur gemapped und hat versucht, Schritt zu halten sozusagen. Und der Fahrer hat noch so ein bisschen dem anderen zugerufen. Jetzt rechts so und so Straße, jetzt hier geradeaus Briefkasten auf 1 Uhr und so. Aber das ging nur, wenn man Schritttempo gefahren ist. Und auch dann war es sehr, sehr anstrengend.
Ich wollte jetzt auch keine Laptop-Benutzung im Auto empfehlen, sondern mir ging es da mehr um diese Stadtteilerfassung.
Ich meinte halt nur, wenn man die Daten gleich in einer polierten Form aufbereitet, sodass man keine Nachbearbeitung mehr zu Hause hat, dann ist es dann ein bisschen mehr als mal eben mit dem Stift auf irgendwas drauf tippen.
Vielleicht gibt es auch einen Zwischenweg. Wenn ich jetzt nur so einen Garmin-GPS-Trekker habe, dann sage ich so, hier Wegpunkt. Was kann ich da schon erfassen? Dann kann ich wahrscheinlich noch komplizierter einen Namen eingeben, damit ich danach auch noch weiß, was dieser Wegpunkt bedeutet.
Die meisten Leute nehmen halt einen Zettel mit und schreiben es sich auf.
Man könnte sich ja auch vorstellen, dass da Software entsteht, die man auf dem Netbook direkt einsetzt, die mehr Metadaten macht, sodass man danach, wenn man zu Hause vor seinem Rechner sitzt, dann Musse hat, die Daten dann auch mit Mehrwert anzureichern. Also sozusagen mehr Basis dafür hat.
Gut wäre das in jedem Fall, insbesondere, weil die Leute natürlich dann auch... Es passiert doch immer mal wieder, dass man dann zu Hause sitzt und aus seiner eigenen Aufzeichnung nicht mehr schlau wird oder einem plötzlich auffällt, hier habe ich das und das vergessen. Würde man vor Ort editieren, dann könnte man in so einem Fall ja immer sagen, ich halte mal kurz an, ich kläre das nochmal hier, wie das genau ist und so Sachen. Das wäre schon sicherlich sehr vielversprechend.
Netbook ist halt schon eigentlich zu groß, um damit mobil arbeiten zu können. Den kann ich nicht auf dem Fahrradlenker irgendwie montieren. Vielleicht kriege ich es gerade irgendwie so hin und dann kommt der Regenschauer und dann ist mein tolles Netbook hin. Das sind natürlich auch so die Sachen, die man da berücksichtigen muss. Ich denke, der Weg wäre da schon mit PDAs in irgendeiner Form zu arbeiten. Wie gesagt, es gibt für das Nokia 810 gibt es eine Software, die heißt OSM2go, mit der man online direkt mappen kann. Die ist relativ neu, aber das funktioniert schon ganz gut. Solange man nur einzelne POIs erfasst, geht es hervorragend. Wenn man wirklich komplett klecksere Sachen hat, dann stößt man auch so an die Grenzen eines kleinen Bildschirms. Da wird sich aber sicher noch viel entwickeln. Das ist eine spannende Frage, was man da noch alles machen kann. Ich denke auch, dass sich das Feld dann noch diversifizieren wird, weil die Straßen sind ja jetzt nun zu großem Teil schon erfasst, zumindest hier in Deutschland. Es wird viel interessanter werden, Spezialinformationen zu haben. Es wird viel mehr Leute geben, die sagen, ich kümmere mich nur um die Tankstellen, weil die mir wichtig sind, oder die Bäckereien, oder was auch immer. Dass es dafür dann spezielle Editoren gibt, oder welche, die nur mit bestimmten Informationen, die zum Beispiel nur POIs erfassen können, das ist ja auch was, was helfen würde. Aber im Moment ist das noch nicht so. Im Moment ist es halt doch noch klassischerweise so, man hat seinen Garmin oder so, läuft damit raus, kommt dann nach Hause und setzt sich da nochmal einen Rechner.
Was könnt ihr denn noch so Leuten, die sich jetzt konkret einbringen wollen, empfehlen? Also ich meine, klar, Daten erfassen, Tracks aufzeichnen, das hatten wir alles schon. Sicherlich jegliches Software-Tool ist noch erwünscht. Gibt es noch so Tipps und Einstiegshilfen? Was sind so eure Tipps, wie man sich so dem Projekt nähern kann, wenn man daran Interesse hat?
Also unser Buch natürlich, müssen wir wieder reklam machen. Da steht natürlich alles drin und kann man lesen. Nee, aber ansonsten, wenn man sich dafür interessiert, die openstreetmap.de Seite, da gibt es ein paar Hinweise, so ersten Einstieg, wie man sowas machen kann. Da kann man rumgucken. Das wäre auch ein guter Ort nachzugucken, wo es andere Mapper gibt in der Gegend. Und das kann ich also jedem empfehlen, dass man einfach zu einem Treffen hingeht, wo andere Leute dabei sind, die schon ein bisschen Erfahrung haben.
Stimmt, es gibt so OpenStreetMap-Communities in vielen Städten, habe ich gesehen, so regelmäßige Treffen.
Ja, und das ist halt sehr gut, weil man da mal jemand hat, dem man die Fragen stellen kann und der einem das vielleicht auch mal zeigen kann, wie man unterwegs ist. In Karlsruhe haben wir jetzt demnächst zum Beispiel so ein Treffen, wo einfach mal gezeigt wird für den Anfänger, so ganz von Null an, wie man irgendwas machen kann. Und da kann jeder vorbeikommen und kann es einfach mal sehen und so ein bisschen über die Anfangshirden hinwegkommen. Und danach kann man dann auch alleine losziehen. Aber gerade beim ersten Mal ist es doch manchmal relativ schwierig, auf was muss ich denn überhaupt alles achten und so weiter. Also bei solchen Mapping-Partys mitzumachen oder eben sich bei so einem Treffen mal mit jemanden zusammen sind und vielleicht dann auch zu verabreden und sagen auch, ja, komm, wir machen mal da zusammen eine Tour. Das ist sicher ein guter Weg, um da einen Einstieg zu finden.
Gibt es auch überregionale OSM-Treffen?
Es gibt das schon erwähnte, diese jährliche Konferenz. In Deutschland hat sich da noch kein richtiges Treffen etabliert. Wir haben diese FOSGIS-Konferenz, die 17. bis 19. März in Hannover stattfinden wird. Da geht es allgemein um free Open Source-Software im GIS-Bereich.
2009, müssen wir dazu sagen, weil Chaos Radio wird ja noch in 500 Jahren gehört.
Ja, richtig, 2009 findet jährlich statt diese Konferenz. Da geht es also allgemein um Geo-Sachen, sage ich jetzt mal, um Open Source-Bereich. Und da ist OpenStreetMap auch mit mehreren Vorträgen vertreten. Und da werden wir einen Stand haben. Es gibt auch sonst immer wieder andere Veranstaltungen auf den Chemnitzer Linux-Tagen. Zum Beispiel wird ein OSM-Stand sein auf dem Linux-Tag. Nehme ich mal an, wird es auch wieder einen geben. Es gibt da immer mehr Veranstaltungen, wo OpenStreetMap sich auch zeigt, sage ich jetzt mal. Und das wäre natürlich auch eine Möglichkeit da, Leute anzusprechen.
Diese ForstGIS-Veranstaltung, die klingt jetzt nach Free Open Source Software. Was ist denn ForstGIS außer OpenStreetMap?
Die ForstGIS-Veranstaltung kommt eigentlich aus diesem professionellen GIS-Bereich, also geografischen Informationssystemen. Das sind also die Vermessungsämter, Leute, die an Unis und so weiter mit professionellen GIS-Systemen arbeiten. Das ist also weniger die Hobbyschiene, aber die Leute sind sehr offen und auch sehr interessiert an OpenStreetMap. OpenStreetMap ist dann der Newcomer in dem Bereich. Aber da gibt es eine riesengroße Software-Szene, die halt Systeme macht, die für die professionellen Choreografen interessant sind und in vielen Fällen auch zu kompliziert für den Hobbyisten schnell sind, obwohl man sich da auch einarbeiten kann. Das kann ich durchaus empfehlen. Da kann man sich das Programm angucken. Die Veranstaltung ist kostenlos. Da kann man einfach so mal vorbeikommen.
In Hannover. Aber die Deutsche OpenStreetMap-Party ist so noch nicht gegründet worden. Da kann sich vielleicht auch mal jemand dran versuchen. Jetzt haben wir hier schon alle ganz erschöpft. Haben wir denn noch irgendwas Wichtiges mitzuteilen, was hier auf jeden Fall noch erwähnt werden sollte?
Ich glaube mir fällt jetzt nichts mehr ein. Ich bin jetzt leergesaugt.
Ich habe dich leer gefragt.
Ich meine, sicherlich gibt es bei dem einen oder anderen Hörer sicherlich noch die eine oder andere Frage offen. Aber das können wir nicht alles vorwegnehmen.
Nein, nein. Dafür gibt es ja dann auch noch das begleitende Blog. Da werden die Leute dann die Fragen dann in die Kommentare werfen. Dazu seid ihr auf jeden Fall aufgefordert. Und ich denke, Jochen und Frederik werden auch eine Weile mitlesen und gegebenenfalls auch antworten. Ja, nun würde ich sagen, bringen wir die Sache zu Ende hier. Vielen Dank für den tiefen Einblick. War auch eine sehr philosophische Sendung. Das mochte ich sehr. Und dann war's das. Chaos Radio Express 113 zu OpenStreetMap. Vielen Dank, Frederik und Jochen, für die Ausführung. Und dann sagen wir hübsch Tschüss zu den Hörern.